An Easy Company, dankeschön für den Sub, Go Wizard, Pock, Subscription, exzellent, das ist sehr, oh warum ist das so leise, Moment jetzt ist das Wub Wub Wub aber viel zu laut, Wub Wub Wub Wub Wub Wub Wub Wub Wub Wub Wub Wub, okay, das ist das beste Plugin ever hier, Browser, Lautstärke, Regelungsplugin, das ist Massive Coggers,
Monka W, so, oh ja, ich bin noch ein bisschen später, weil ich hab heute das gemacht, was meine Garmin Uhr gesagt hat, nämlich eine Stunde 15 am Stück rennen und das hab ich auch wirklich bis auf die Minute gemacht, deswegen war ich nochmal eine Viertelstunde länger unterwegs wie sonst und ich musste zwischendurch, ey, so nach 20 Minuten rennen musste ich so krass aufs Klo und ich konnte dann nicht für eine weitere Stunde,
deswegen musste ich jetzt auch erst nochmal eine Viertelstunde aufs Klo, ich weiß, das wolltet ihr sicherlich alle wissen jetzt, deswegen bin ich jetzt erst da, aber das macht nix, deswegen sind bestimmt auch mehr Leute wach, beziehungsweise ready zum Aufwachen,
oh, das ist echt nicht ohne, ey, 1,15 am Stück rennen, das merkst du richtig, dass es auf die Beine geht, aber ich bin zum Glück nicht so schnell gerannt,
Ziel ist ja, demnächst mal über 20 Kilometer, ungefähr in dem Tempo wie heute wahrscheinlich, dass ich das auch durchhalte, so, ich mach mal kurz meine VM an, weil Arch, by the way, oder gibt's garantiert Updates, ja, VM, wir gehen ja nicht auf den Sack,
okay, wait, übrigens, wisst ihr, was ich gesehen hab, was ich gerne, also eine Sache, die ich gesehen hab, die mich ein bisschen nervt ist, Unraid hat neue Lizenz,
irgendwas, Zeug, ich find's jetzt gerade nicht, also ich benutze das ja auf meinem HP Microserver, weil es das ist, was mich bisher am wenigsten genervt hat, wobei ich sagen muss, großer Unraid-Fan bin ich nach wie vor nicht, auch wenn ich's benutze,
zumindest, die sind jetzt der Meinung, dass sie ihr Lifetime-License-Modell, also bisher konntest du dir, ich zeig euch mal, also bisher konnte man sich eine Lizenz kaufen, passend zum Speicherplatz,
Basic-Lizenz gekauft, für 60 Dollar, ich finde 60 Dollar quasi für Lizenz, Linux-Distribution plus Updates und letztendlich fließt da natürlich auch viel Entwicklung in das Web-Interface und alles rein,
finde ich durchaus eine faire Sache und das konntest du so lange verwenden, wie du den USB-Stick verwendet hast, mit dem du die Lizenz registriert hast, das war quasi gebunden immer an den USB-Stick,
beziehungsweise an die Hardware-ID von dem Device, wo du das drauf installiert hast.
So, und jetzt sind sie auf die Chlor-Reihe, also ich finde, das war eigentlich recht fair bisher, ja, 60 Euro, dann konntest du halt so lange benutzen, wie das Device gelebt hat, für das du es registriert hast,
die Dinger leben ja auch nicht ewig, also irgendwie ab und zu mal neu, musste man sich das eh kaufen, so, und letztendlich konnte man hier nur noch mehr Devices anschließen, der Rest war alles das gleiche.
Dann haben die sich gedacht, nope, das ist zu billig.
Das geht nicht, deswegen gibt es jetzt ein neues Lizenz-Modell, und zwar, so wie alle, ein Abo-Modell.
Und da habe ich ehrlich gesagt schon mal überhaupt keinen Bock drauf.
Man kann die Lizenz übertragen, okay, ich kann nicht neu kaufen müssen.
Jetzt haben sie sich gedacht, wir machen ein Abo-Modell, ab nächster Woche.
Ein Abo-Modell, und zwar, hey, das kleine Abo-Modell, ja, fängt...
Sieht 10 Dollar günstiger an, wie das aktuelle Lizenz-Modell, aber du kriegst bloß nur für ein Jahr Updates.
Danach kostet dich das 36 Dollar pro Jahr, dass du weiter Updates, also Annual ist jährlich, dass du weiter Updates bekommst.
Das braucht im Prinzip keiner, und jetzt die Lifetime-Lizenz für immer, Unlimited Devices, also das, was vorher Pro war,
das kostet jetzt einfach das Doppelte.
Daran sieht man mal, wie viel das unterm Strich wäre.
Also das kostet ziemlich genau das Doppelte.
Ja, also hier, das würde 260 kosten, das kostet 250 jetzt, ja.
Also das kostet das Doppelte von dem, was es jetzt gekostet hätte.
Also, und ich muss halt ehrlich sagen, mich fucken Abo-Modelle einfach nur ab.
Überall, jede Mist will Abo-Modelle.
Du brauchst drei Streaming-Services, Musik-Services, Backup-Services, Cloud-Services, alles wirklich.
Du hast ja, bloß die Sachen, die du vorhast, du hast ja mittlerweile 30 plus Abos, wenn du alles auf, sagen wir mal, offiziellem Wege beziehst.
Betrifft das die bestehenden Lizenzen?
Nein, die bestehenden Lizenzen bleiben gleich, aber natürlich beziehen wir immer alles auf offiziellen Wegen, weil alles andere wäre ja nicht erlaubt.
Und das ist übrigens auch ein Grund, ich habe es im letzten Stream schon gesagt, ich habe in letzter Zeit total viele Animes geguckt.
Und das liegt zum größten Teil, ich war früher nie der große Anime-Gucker, das liegt daran, weil mir die ganzen Streaming-Dienste so auf den Sack gehen und zum Anime-Stream brauchst du keinen Streaming-Dienst.
Das ist zwar, das ist zwar, sagen wir mal, Grauzone, aber es funktioniert gut.
Bald kommt...
Das ist doch schon so.
Ist das nicht so, dass du bei BMW für Firmware-Features Abo-Kosten hast?
Ich bilde mir ein, ich habe da mal was gelesen.
15k für Abos ist natürlich schon ordentlich, aber klar, je nachdem, was das ist, das läppert sich.
Du denkst dir immer so, ja, hier mal ein Abo.
Guck mal, allein schon, allein schon das Abo, was ich für die Jetbrain-IDEs bezahle.
Oh, hier haben wir noch Docker-Stells.
Ich meine, allein schon das hier.
Was bezahle ich?
Da bezahle ich doch im Jahr auch schon.
Ja, ja, I want it all, bla, bla.
Pricing for individual use.
So, ich bin jetzt im Trainern.
Also, mal hier 170 Euro, mal da 30 Euro, mal da irgendwie wieder 100 Euro.
Ich meine, da kommst du vielleicht jetzt nicht unbedingt jeder auf 15.000 Euro.
Das wäre schon echt ordentlich, ja.
Aber je nachdem, was du da abonnierst, kann das durchaus sein, ja.
Das ist...
Dann bezahle ich für meine...
Fahrrad-App bezahle ich 12 Euro, glaube ich, im Monat.
Für YouTube Premium bezahle ich Geld, wobei ich das nicht in Deutschland kaufe.
Für...
Prime.
Ich muss mal das mal...
Ich müsste mir eigentlich, ohne Scheiß, ich müsste mir eigentlich mal...
OnlyFans natürlich, keck, wait.
Ähm, nee.
Ich müsste mir echt mal eine Liste machen mit allen Abos, dass ich da irgendwie einen Überblick habe.
Ich...
Das ist ja auch die Gefahr von dem ganzen Abo-Kram.
Du denkst dir so, ach, das kostet 15 Euro oder so, oder es kostet 5 Euro im Monat, oder es kostet jährlich irgendwie 80 Euro und so.
Das ist doch eigentlich kein Ding.
Können wir mal machen.
Komod für die Wande...
Für die Wande-App.
Die wollen auch ein Premium-Abo jetzt verkaufen und sowas in der Richtung.
Redest du oder ist das wirklich so?
Also, wie gesagt, ich bilde mir ein, ich habe bei BMW mal gelesen.
Du bezahlst bei BMW...
Ja, Adobe-Abo...
Warum dir jeder Scheiß im Abo vertickt wird.
Gutes...
Gutes Thema.
Passt, das können wir uns gleich angucken.
Ähm...
Alleine um alle Spiele für...
Ja, wenn man Sport gucken will, kostet das auch extreme...
Viele verschiedene Abos.
Du brauchst ja, wenn du alles sehen willst, glaube ich, Datsen, Premiere und noch irgendwas?
Prime?
Wenn du wirklich alles...
Also, wenn man wirklich so eine krasse Fußball...
Und das ist ja nur für Fußball.
Wenn du sagen, wenn du jetzt mal irgendwie Radsport gucken willst oder so,
da brauchst du ja noch mehr, da brauchst du dann irgendwie noch hier...
Da ein Streaming-Service, manches wird nur von irgendeinem australischen Streaming-Service übertragen.
Ganz, ganz wirr, ja?
Also, das nervt mich.
Das nervt mich extrem, dieses ganze Abo-Zeug.
Deswegen bin ich jetzt echt zum Anime-Gucker geworden.
Da hast du die Probleme nicht mit Abo-Services.
So, ich mach mal kurz Arch, by the way, Package-Updates.
Docker, geh aus.
Jawoll, Updates, das machen wir auch aus.
Machen wir auch aus, brauchen wir jetzt alles nicht.
Package-Updates.
Im Prinzip hat das mit den Handys schon angefangen.
Gürtel, die Handys mit tollem Vertrag.
Ja, schon.
Wobei das ja immer Gerätesubventionierung noch so mit dabei war.
Also, ja, aber du hast...
Das ging schon, das geht schon richtig.
Ich meine, wir dürfen nicht vergessen,
viele Spiele, die wir jetzt noch nicht haben,
viele Spiele,
wollen dir ja auch irgendwelche Dinger aufs Auge drücken.
Da haben wir uns zwar ein bisschen wegbewegt
von den klassischen Monats-Payment-Modellen,
wie das früher bei MMOs am Start war,
aber die sind natürlich auch sehr daran interessiert,
dass du permanent Geld reinsteckst
für irgendeinen neuen Season Pass
oder für irgendwelche Unlocks
oder irgendwelche Cosmetics und sonst was.
Welche Docker benutzt du in deinem Unrainers?
Was?
Die Frage verstehe ich nicht.
Gibt es mehr als einen Docker?
So.
Archlinux, by the way.
Leute, ich habe gestern auf Twitter gefragt, ja,
was würdet ihr einem 76-jährigen Rentner
für einen Linux empfehlen?
Und ich war wirklich schockiert.
Keiner der Leute auf Twitter hat gepostet,
Archlinux mit i3.
Kann ich gar nicht verstehen.
Für einen 76-jährigen Rentner, der nur Windows kennt,
ist Archlinux mit i3 doch eindeutig easy, easy going.
Da kann er wenigstens nichts kaputt machen,
weil er nichts machen kann.
Wer nichts machen kann, kann auch nichts kaputt machen.
Also die Frage hatte tatsächlich...
Das war keine rein rhetorische Frage,
die ich auf Twitter gestellt habe,
nur für den Sinn des Fragestellens,
um zu wissen, was ihr darauf antwortet.
Also meine...
Warte mal.
Ach so.
Moment.
Twitter ist ja scheiße nach der Übernahme.
Habe ich ja vergessen.
Der zeigt mir ja nicht an, was da...
Ja, nice.
Also das hatte ich ja gestern gefragt hier.
Bestes...
Ach so.
Moment.
Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Man sieht noch nicht mal mehr die Antworten auf Twitter mittlerweile,
wenn man nicht eingeloggt ist.
Wirklich?
Seit wann denn das jetzt?
Das ist aber auch neu, oder?
Aber das wird echt immer beschissener.
Das kommt ja auch noch dazu.
Twitter will übrigens auch ein Abo von mir haben, ne?
Das kommt ja noch dabei,
dass viele Sachen jetzt immer mehr auf Abo umstellen,
aber die Sachen noch immer beschissener werden.
So.
Und da haben die Leute gesagt,
die Leute haben alles Mögliche drauf geantwortet,
bloß nicht Archlinux mit i3.
Ich war sehr enttäuscht.
Naja, ich lösche meinen Account bestimmt nicht.
Auf X ist es jetzt ja.
Habe ich jetzt...
Leute, habe ich jetzt rebooted oder nicht?
Ich glaube, ich habe rebooted, ne?
Na, dann ist alles gut.
Ich glaube, ich habe rebooted.
Ja.
Naja, zumindest...
Ja, ich sage da gar nichts.
Das Problem ist, dass du mittlerweile so viele Abos brauchst,
wohingegen du vor ein paar Jahren...
noch quasi Spotify oder Prime Music Pro oder wie das hieß,
abonnieren musstest.
Oder Netflix oder Prime...
Irgendwann...
Musst du ja heute für Filme gucken,
fast schon drei bis vier verschiedene Streaming-Services abonnieren.
Und da ist...
Leute, die Sport gucken wollen, mal gar nicht mit dabei.
Ja.
Zumindest wollen die jetzt...
Um mal wieder zurückzukommen zu der ganzen...
Zumindest wollen die jetzt auch umschwenken auf ein Abo-Modell.
Aber hierzu...
Ja.
So, dass das Teuerste quasi doppelt so viel kostet.
Und das finde ich kacke.
Ach ja, übrigens.
Wisst ihr, was ich auch witzig finde?
Die haben da so eine FAQ drunter.
Guckt mal.
FAQ.
Ist...
Also, Leute.
Würdet ihr sagen, dass...
Kaufen plus jährlich verlängern ein Abo-Modell ist?
Für mich klingt das verdächtig nach einem Abo-Modell.
Kaufen und dann jährlich verlängern.
Findet ihr, dass das ein Abo-Modell ist?
Also, ich finde, das ist ein Abo-Modell.
So.
Aber Unrate sagt...
Ist Unrate US a Subscription?
No.
Nein.
Kaufen und jährlich verlängern ist definitiv kein Abo-Modell.
No.
Ist kein Abo-Modell.
We don't like forced subscription either.
Das ist ja schön für euch.
Ihr müsst ja euren eigenen Kram nicht kaufen.
Und dann...
Und dann dichten sie sich irgendwie zusammen mit...
Ja.
Du kannst das ja ohne Updates einfach weiter betreiben.
Du musst ja gar kein Abo kaufen.
Du kannst ein Abo kaufen.
Naja.
Für mich, mit meinem Geschmack, ist das immer noch ein Abo-Modell.
Das finde ich ein bisschen kacke.
Auf der anderen Seite, ich habe ja hier meine Lizenz und...
Das tut schon.
Ich meine, wirklich glücklich mit Unrate bin ich eh nicht.
Aber die Alternativen gefallen mir auch alle nicht.
Ich...
Ich sehe schon kommen.
Ich lande einfach wieder, auch privat, auf einem simplen Debian-Server, wo ich alles selbst mache.
Wie das bei Wies4 ist, ehrlich gesagt, ich glaube, da gibt es aktuell keinen, der dir das gescheit erklären kann.
Weil seit der...
Was war das?
Broadcom?
Wer hat vor allem übernommen?
Broadcom, oder?
Ich glaube Broadcom.
Broadcom hat das übernommen.
Und da blickt keiner mehr durch, wie das abgeht jetzt mit Lizenzen und wie da was funktioniert.
Ich erst recht nicht.
Ich beschäftige mich ja hauptberuflich nicht mit VMware.
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Aber ich weiß, dass unsere VMware-Leute da auch nicht durchblicken.
Und wahrscheinlich blickt da VMware selbst nicht mal durch.
War bei uns auf der Arbeit auch was Lustiges letztens gewesen.
Die haben irgendeine ganz uralte Legacy-Anwendung, die auf irgendeine noch ältere Legacy, SAP, HANA, frag mich nicht, Datenbank oder...
Nee.
Oder Sybase.
Irgendwas ganz Altes.
Irgendwas ganz Altes zugreift.
So, und da brauchen die, also die Datenbank, die ist mittlerweile so fett geworden, dass irgendwie entweder, ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, was es ist.
Ja, ich war da, ich habe das nur am Rande mitgekriegt.
Entweder ist die Datenbank so fett, dass sie es nicht gescheit gestort kriegen und die irgendwie auch splitten müssen.
Oder, dass sie das jetzt irgendwie speziell indizieren müssen, dass es irgendwie performant bleibt.
Ist auch scheißegal, das ist wurscht.
Zumindest gibt es ja jetzt das Ding, das zwei Möglichkeiten.
Entweder.
Oder, die migrieren das Ding auf Postgres und alles wäre gut.
Oder, die kaufen sich für, frag mich nicht, 80.000 Euro im Jahr eine Zusatzlizenz, eine Extended Support Lizenz, inklusive, ja, Feature Unlock Lizenz, damit sie das Alte so weiter betreiben können, wie es ist.
Plus diesen, was zur damaligen Zeitpunkt quasi nicht offiziell supported war, Feature einschalten zu dürfen in der uralten Version, dass es schneller geht.
So, und jetzt dreimal dürft ihr raten, wofür man sich entscheidet.
80.000 Euro Legacy Premium Lizenz oder Postgres upgraden, auf Postgres umziehen.
Easy, ja, natürlich.
Korrekt.
Man schmeißt einfach Geld drauf.
Und hat irgendeine weitere uralte Datenbank Legacy Technologie, die man weiter betreiben muss.
Da war letztens noch irgendwas, fand ich auch geil.
Sie haben irgendeine Software, wo die Version nicht mehr zur Datenbank geht.
Nee, warte mal, wie war das? Okay, lass mich mal überlegen.
Ja, genau.
Die haben irgendeine Software, die läuft gegen eine uralte Oracle Datenbank.
In dem Fall ist es Oracle, das weiß ich.
Daniel Lull, Dankeschön für den Sub.
Mal gucken, ob ich irgendwelche Subscriptions übersehen habe, aber ich glaube nicht.
Die haben irgendeine Software, die läuft gegen eine uralte Oracle Datenbank.
Und ich bin mir nicht mehr ganz sicher, wie das ist.
Aber also.
Ich bin mir nicht hundertprozentig sicher, wie es ist.
Also, ich glaube, es ist so.
Die.
Es kann sein, dass es Mist ist, was ich jetzt erzähle, aber ich glaube, so ungefähr ist es.
So, die müssen ihr Linux upgraden jetzt von Red Hat 7 auf Red Hat 8.
Also, ihr merkt, diese Systeme sind super aktuell jetzt schon.
Red Hat 7 kam raus.
Moment, das ist erst vier Jahre alt.
Nee, nee.
2014, ja, das, das, das, das kommt mir realistischer vor.
2014, ja, das, das, das kommt hin.
Also, das sind Systeme wahrscheinlich, die sind wahrscheinlich noch älter von 2014.
Und da ist es jetzt so, die müssen ihre Systeme upgraden von Red Hat 7 auf Red Hat 8,
weil man sieht es ja hier, Red Hat, Red Hat 7 ist, ist demnächst hier out of support.
Zumindest ist das Ding.
Die haben noch eine Anwendung drauf, die greift mit irgendeinem offiziellen,
ein Oracle-Client auf eine Oracle-Datenbank zu.
Und jetzt ist es so, dass die das upgraden müssen, aber auf Red Hat 8 funktioniert der alte Oracle-Client nicht mehr.
Und die Software selbst ist nur zertifiziert mit dieser alten Oracle-Version.
Das heißt, du musst dir jetzt überlegen, entweder du upgradest die Software mal, die da drauf läuft,
damit die auch mit dem neuen Oracle-Client funktioniert, oder, und jetzt kommt der Hammer,
oder du kaufst dir irgendeine super extended Support-Geschichte von Red Hat und Oracle,
die 150.000, das ist jetzt ungelogen, Leute, 150.000 Euro im Jahr kostet.
Zusatzlizenz, 150.000 Euro, musst du dir mal auf der Zunge zergehen lassen, kostet das mehr,
damit man das so lassen kann für noch eine Weile.
Und was macht man?
Man kann auch da 150.000 Euro im Jahr ausgeben für diese komische Lizenz.
Das ist das übertriebenste Keg-Business.
Wer Keg-Business gibt, geht gar nicht mehr.
Manchmal denke ich mir auch, die haben echt so viel Geld.
Das ist wirklich so.
Das ist wirklich Pay-Per-Burn-Money.
Wir sind wirklich Meister der Legacy-Systeme bei uns in der Versicherung.
Wirklich, wo du hinguckst, wo du hinguckst, steht irgendein Uralt-System.
Die haben, wisst ihr, was ich letztens sogar gehört habe von einem?
Die haben Solaris-Kisten noch als, oh, ich habe vergessen, wie sie das genannt haben.
Die sind quasi nicht wirklich mehr am Netz und machen nicht wirklich was.
Die sind quasi nur noch so als, ja, Archiv oder sowas vorhanden.
Solaris im Jahr 2024, da weiß der echt nicht mehr weiter, ey.
Ich bin nur froh, dass ich mit diesen ganzen ollen Legacy-Systemen nichts zu tun habe.
Und auch jedes Mal, wenn da irgendeiner kommt und sagt, hier, Max, willst du da nicht was?
Nein, will ich nicht.
Ich mache nur halbwegs neue Sachen.
Also alles, was schon Linux ist, okay, und was Google Cloud und Cloud-Infrastruktur angeht,
das mache ich eh am liebsten.
Da bist du nämlich gezwungen, dass es halbwegs aktuell ist,
weil die dieses sonst zwangsupgraden oder gar nicht mehr supporten.
Naja, auf Geldautomaten läuft es auch teilweise.
Auch noch Windows XP oder Windows 98 oder so.
Ja, wir gucken uns mal übrigens gerade mal wieder an, was auf ShitHub so trennet.
Übrigens, eine Sache, wisst ihr, was auch eine Sache ist, die ich mir unbedingt im Stream mit euch mal angucken will?
Ich habe gesehen, es gibt ein ESP32C4, dieses Ding.
Das würde ich unglaublich gerne mal ausprobieren.
Mal gucken, ob man den Kram auch auf Amazon kriegt.
Weil, ah, da muss man, ach guck mal, doch, gibt es, gibt es, ne, gibt es nicht.
Muss man, muss man bei denen wahrscheinlich direkt bestellen.
Aber die, die haben auch einen Shop irgendwie, man kann das auch nach Deutschland bestellen.
Halbwegs, halbwegs gescheit.
Zumindest, warum ich mir das Ding bestellen will, ist folgendes.
Das ist ein ESP32, sag mal, ist es nicht der originale ESP32, ist der ESP32C6.
Der hat, glaube ich, kein Dual-Core und sonst was, aber scheiß drauf.
Aber, das nice ist, der hat Zigbee.
Und BLE, also BLE hat der andere ja auch, aber der hat neuen Wifi-Support, neuen BLE-Support und Zigbee-Support.
Beziehungsweise Thread.
Und da kann man, theoretisch damit, sein eigenes Zigbee-IoT-Gerät bauen.
Und das für 4,88.
Ich wollte nämlich schon, das ist so ein Ding, was ich seit Jahren mit mir rumschleppe, was immer nicht richtig funktioniert.
Ich habe doch einen Teich hinten im Garten.
Und der droht im Winter ab und zu zuzufrieren.
Und da habe ich so einen Thermometer drin hängen, um auszulesen, wann es soweit ist, dass ich den rechtzeitig zudecken kann.
Man könnte den jetzt einfach immer zudecken, Anfang vom Winter.
Aber da sind Fische drin, die müssen ja auch nicht unnötig keine Sonne kriegen und sowas.
Oder kein Licht abkriegen.
Also, insofern, ich decke das Ding nur zu, wenn es quasi so kalt wird.
Wenn es so kalt wird, dass es gefriert wird.
Ja, weil wenn man das nicht zudeckt und es gefriert, dann kann es sein, dass es am Rand platzt.
Das ist auch nicht gut.
So, und ich hatte das bisher so gemacht.
Also, ich hatte lange Zeit da einen Thermometer drin.
So einen, wie heißen diese Dinger?
DS2818 oder sowas?
Ne, das da?
Ne, aber wie heißen diese Dinger?
DS18B20?
Ja.
Die Dinger.
So einen Teil hatte ich da die ganze Zeit drin hängen.
An einem zweckentfremdeten Z-Wave-Fensterkontakt, wo man Sensoren anlöten kann.
Das hat aber nie wirklich gut funktioniert mit der Kommunikation.
Obwohl ich eine Z-Wave-Steckdose hatte damals, nebendran, als Repeater.
Das hat nicht wirklich gut funktioniert.
Danach habe ich was mit BLE probiert zum Weiterleiten.
Hat auch nicht gut funktioniert.
Und das Ding ist halt, das muss dort mit Batterie laufen.
Das muss mit Batterie laufen.
Weil das ist halt mitten im Garten.
Da habe ich keinen Stecker.
Ja, das hilft aber nicht immer.
Ich habe so eine Pumpe.
Ja.
Aber selbst das friert teilweise zu.
Also wenn es richtig paar Tage richtig kalt ist.
Ich habe so ein Ding.
Ich habe so ein Ding drin hängen.
So und.
Und selbst wenn, selbst wenn, es ist nice die Temperatur zu wissen.
Und deswegen wollte ich mal ein eigenes ZigBee-Gerät bauen.
Und das scheint mir das beste Board dafür zu sein.
Kostet 5,88€.
Ach ja, und warum dieses Board genau?
Weil dieses Board ein Ultra Low Power ist.
Ultra Low Power Board.
Was nur im Deep Sleep nur 14 Mikroampere braucht.
Nicht Milli, Mikro.
Und damit kann man mit so einer handelsüblichen 1200 Milliampere Stunden Lithium Batterie oder Akku.
Kann man das Ding wahrscheinlich dann durchaus da eineinhalb Jahre liegen lassen.
Selbst wenn du plus minus 20% und alles.
Das schwimmt schon diese, diese Pumpe.
Das, das, das schwimmt schon auf so einem Ding.
Da werde ich, da werde ich versuchen mal sowas zu bauen.
Mini Solarpanel drauf.
Ja, die Idee ist, die Idee ist nicht schlecht.
Das Ding ist.
Mit einem Solarpanel alleine.
Bringt es dir auch nicht.
Das ist.
Das wusste ich früher auch nicht.
Das ist gar nicht so einfach.
Damit du mit Solar laden kannst, brauchst du erst einmal logischerweise.
Irgendein Solarpanel.
Dann brauchst du einen Microcontroller.
Der oder, oder, ja, oder auch eine.
Es muss kein, es muss kein Microcontroller sein.
Kann auch eine eigene, eigene Schaltung sein.
Du brauchst einen Akku und du brauchst Ladeelektronik dafür.
Wenn du Glück hast, hast du einen Microcontroller.
Ein Microcontroller, der das integriert hat und ein Batterieanschluss.
Das weiß ich nicht, ob der sowas hat.
Also der, der Fire Beetle hatte das.
Der hier hat das glaube ich nicht, wenn ich.
Also so ein Produktfoto hätte man natürlich auch nicht scharf machen können.
Das war nicht im Scope.
Der hat kein, doch guck mal.
Nee, nee, nee, aber da ist kein Lade.
Da ist kein Lade Dings dahinter.
Das ist einfach nur ein weiterer, ein weiterer 3,3 Volt.
Anschluss, denke ich mal.
Supports Batterie, echt?
Ach ja.
Dann ist das ein richtig, also wenn, wenn da wirklich Ladeelektronik für einen Akku drin ist schon.
Dann ist das ein richtig gutes Allround Board für Low Power Sachen.
Weil dann kannst du da tatsächlich dein, wobei Battery Charging, nee, nee, nee, nee.
Damit meinen die, dass du eine Batterie dranhängen kannst.
Und wenn du dann USB Power einstöpselst, dann lädt er die Batterie.
Der hat keine Ladeelektronik für, für Solarpanels drinne oder sowas.
Naja, Lithium Battery Management.
Vielleicht doch, vielleicht doch, ja.
Also wenn, wenn wäre mega, dann ist das ein richtig gutes Board.
Da muss ich mir da gleich mal welche bestellen.
Haben die auch einen deutschen Shop irgendwie?
Der Eckstein Shop, alles genau das ist.
Wo kann ich mir dieses Ding kaufen in Deutschland?
Computer.de
Ach guck mal, die haben das Teil hier auch.
Warum kostet das das Doppelte in Euro als in Dollar?
Was ist denn das schon wieder?
Anzeige ist raus.
Ich meine, ist jetzt nicht schlimm.
Moment, das ist ein, das ist ein anderes.
Das ist ein anderes.
Das ist der Fire, Fire Beetle 2.
Das ist ein anderes Board.
Das ist ein Board, wo du noch irgendwie, keine Ahnung, was auch immer hast.
Gut, wie dem auch sei, ich muss mir das mal in Ruhe angucken.
Das machen wir jetzt nicht im Stream.
Und demnächst müssen wir noch ein bisschen Proggerstells machen.
Da habe ich, da habe ich richtig Bock drauf.
Mal wieder ein bisschen Microcontroller-Stells zu programmieren.
Lass uns doch mal checken, was denn auf Shithub diese Woche so trendet.
Da freust du dich, Proggerstells, ja.
Ich auch.
Was trendet denn diese Woche so auf?
Ah, China-Chinesen-Kram oder japanischer Kram.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Was ist das?
Es ist, Auswahl übersetzen auf Englisch.
Es ist Chinesisch.
Shang Shu Notes Comment Crawler.
Comment Crawler, Video Comment Crawler, Video Comment, Waibu Post Crawler.
Ah ja.
Hast du den Prometheus-Exporter auf der Arbeit ausprobiert?
Eine exzellente Frage.
Ja, habe ich.
Sehr gute Frage, da kann ich tatsächlich noch was kurz zu erzählen.
Habe ich ausprobiert.
Und nicht nur ausprobiert.
Ich habe das Ding nochmal neu gebaut.
Halt mit den passenden Werten, also mit passenden Metriken, die wir brauchen.
Und den richtigen API-Abfragen.
Das war ja nur getestet hier im Stream.
Ich habe das Ding nochmal neu gebaut.
Ich habe ein Image gebaut und in unserer Testumgebung das Deployment im Kubernetes Cluster gepatcht,
sodass mein Image als Sidecar injectet wird und anfängt die Metriken zu exportieren.
Und jetzt haben wir ein Dashboard, wo Block Age, Block ID und Block Timestamp drinnen sichtbar ist.
Ja.
Es hat sich gelohnt, dass wir das hier im Stream ausprobiert haben.
Easy.
Eats.
Eats AF.
Ich mache sowas gerne.
Einzig dumme ist, ich glaube, bis auf ein anderer bei mir im Team, oder zwei, zwei, bis auf zwei andere bei mir im Team,
geht das interessensmäßig bei denen echt so ein bisschen vorbei.
Die anderen sind quasi hauptsächlich so weniger Programmierer, eher reine Linux-Admins.
Und es gibt vielleicht zwei Leute im Team, die sich für sowas noch interessieren.
Außer mich, also außer ich.
Deswegen erzähle ich sowas gar nicht bei uns in Teamrunden mit Custom Metric Exporter und sonst was.
Da musst du dir nur von manchen Leuten blöde Fragen anhören und dann eine halbe Stunde erklären, um was es eigentlich geht.
Da habe ich keinen Bock drauf.
Aber unsere Anwendungsverantwortlichen freuen sich extrem, dass sie ein schönes Dashboard haben, um zu sehen, ob das Ding hinterherhängt oder nicht.
Ich muss denen mal sagen.
Ich sage ja immer, man muss nicht nur nice Sachen machen, man muss auch drüber reden, dass man nice Sachen gemacht hat.
Ich muss unseren Anwendungsverantwortlichen mal sagen, wenn die meinen Chef sehen, sollen sie ihm mal erzählen, wie nice die das finden.
Man muss ja immer ein bisschen darauf bedacht sein, dass es gut ankommt.
So, wo bin ich jetzt gerade stehen geblieben?
Shithub Trend Repos.
Was verdient dein Chef?
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Vermutlich ein bisschen mehr, aber nicht so viel mehr.
Dass ich mir jemals den Stress geben würde, diesen Job machen zu wollen.
Im Leben nicht.
Alter Chat, was ist mit euch los?
Ihr seid so aggressive heute.
Also ich hätte niemals Bock drauf, Teamleiter, Gruppenleiter, Abteilungsleiter oder sowas zu werden.
Ich habe kein Problem damit, mehr Geld zu bekommen.
Allerdings dann für Technik-Sachen und nicht für irgendwelche Personal- und Management-Verantwortungs- oder Projektmanagement-Sachen.
Also wenn das das einzige ist, womit man mehr Geld bekommen kann, dann werde ich das nicht machen.
Oder was anderes suchen, wo man mit Technik mehr Geld verdienen kann.
Aber glücklicherweise hat das Unternehmen, wo ich arbeite, das schon vor einer Weile gecheckt, sodass du dort auch in technischer Sicht Möglichkeiten hast, den Karriere-Crime zu starten, wenn man auf sowas Bock hat.
Aber ihr wisst, Karriere-Crime ist bei mir eben. Da bin ich eh der Falsche für.
Ich mache einfach nice Sachen.
Und erzähle denen so lange, dass ich nice Sachen mache, bis sie mir mehr Geld geben.
Und wenn es mir gar so lange dauert, dann muss man halt mal weiter gucken.
Aber aktuell ist es ja alles gut.
Aktuell passt ja alles. Es gibt ordentlich Kohle, nice Home-Office-Regelungen, Team passt, Aufgaben passen zum größten Teil.
Es gibt ein paar Sachen, die dir auf den Sack gehen.
Also aktuell gibt es ja echt keinen Grund, sich da zu beschweren.
Das ist eine richtige Boomer-Aussage.
Ey, Nara, weißt du was?
Sind das die gleichen Leute, die Märchensteuer anstatt Mehrwertsteuer sagen?
Ich könnte wetten, das sind die gleichen Leute.
Das sind solche Leute, die machen das.
Ja.
Das ist so ein richtiges Boomer-Wort, Alter. Märchensteuer.
Ja, mache ich. Und ich bin auch regelmäßig am Flamen auf Twitter.
Nee, hab ich nicht.
Home-Office wird bei uns immer mehr abgebaut.
Ich wollte ja schon so vor über einem Monat mal ein Video zu dem Thema machen,
dass es bei immer mehr Unternehmen hier Return to Office heißt.
Aufhänger des Ganzen wollte ich nehmen.
Irgendeinen Post von irgendeinem CEO, den ich gar nicht namentlich erwähnen will in meinem Video,
weil er hat den Post mittlerweile gelöscht, der sich auch darüber aufgeregt hat, wie dreist die Leute mittlerweile sind,
dass sie lieber Home-Office arbeiten wollen, anstatt zwei Stunden am Tag hin- und zurückfahren und sowas.
Ganz, ganz weird, weird champiger Post war das.
Ja, schon lange nicht mehr.
Das liegt aber auch an mir. Ich habe mich ja auch ewig nicht gemeldet.
Ihr wisst, wie nice ich bin im sozialen Umgang mit anderen Leuten.
Wie skilled ich da bin.
Zwischenprüfung war Multiple-Choice?
War Zwischenprüfung Multiple-Choice? Ich kann mich gar nicht mehr an die Zwischenprüfung erinnern.
Egal. Also, AI wird geskippt.
AI, AI, AI, AI, AI.
Vintage S. Ein neues JavaScript-Framework. Endlich.
Moment, ist das nicht der Swell-Typ?
Ne, der sah nur so aus wie der Swell-Typ.
Vintage S. Was ist das schon wieder?
Blazingly fast JavaScript-Server that runs Service-Worker-Scripts.
Äh, Moment.
Es ist ein JavaScript-Service für...
Ich verstehe nicht mal, was das sein soll.
Was im...
Was im Server-Side, oder was?
Alter, es wird ja immer verrückter mit Web-Geschichten.
Was im Server-Side?
Warum nicht...
Okay, mag ja durchaus Sinn machen, wenn man das Gleiche im Frontend...
Keine Ahnung.
Web-Entwicklungs-Stelzer. Weiß nicht.
Hyper.
Rust. Written in Rust. Blazingly fast.
Aber so richtig verstehen den Sinn davon tue ich immer noch nicht.
Die About-Beschreibung ist ja auch sehr hilfreich.
Ist der Stream lagging gerade?
Also, ich bin mir nicht so ganz sicher, was der Sinn davon ist jetzt gerade, aber...
Man kann jetzt quasi Web-Assembly-Zeug auf dem Server laufen.
Ich dachte immer, der eigentliche Sinn von Web-Assembly wäre, dass man...
...Libraries und sowas, die es für, sagen wir mal, klassische Programmiersprachen gab...
...die halt eher auf dem Server laufen, auch im Browser verwenden kann und nicht umgedreht.
Also sprich, warum muss ich beispielsweise eine C++-Sache benutzen auf dem Server...
...in Web-Assembly, wenn ich die doch einfach auch direkt kompilieren kann.
Irgendwas, was auf dem Server läuft.
Es scheint mir auch im Hype zu sein, ich verstehe aber gerade den Sinn davon nicht.
Ich meine, es ist Blazingly fast, written in Rust.
Allein schon, dass die ganzen Krustentiere sich daran jetzt aufgeilen, ist klar, dass das im Hype ist.
Aber so ganz... Wahrscheinlich checke ich einfach nur den Sinn nicht richtig.
Web-Interoperable-Runtimes-Community-Group.
What? Web-Platform-APIs-Outside-the-Browser.
Okay. Ich habe absolut keinen blassen Schimmer.
Ich weiß nicht, was das eigentlich sein soll.
Aber es scheint eine nice Technologie zu sein.
Ohne, dass ich es wirklich verstehe.
Okay, was haben wir denn auch noch? AI. AI. AI. AI.
Ach, guck mal. YouTube-Downloader in Go.
Lux. Aha. Das Allerwichtigste. Chat. Wir müssen checken, ob Pornhub supported wird.
Aha. Aha. Anscheinend. Anscheinend schon. Okay.
Dann hat es ja den Zweck erfüllt.
AI. AI. Das Ding ist, warum ich das gucke.
Wenn diese Seiten funktionieren, dann funktionieren wahrscheinlich die meisten anderen Seiten auch.
Weil gerade Porn-Seiten irgendwie einen Hang dazu haben, ihren Web-Player so zu gestalten, dass die Videos nur über die Seite wiedergegeben werden können.
Das ist halt Werbung und alles läuft bei denen.
Ja, und die versuchen halt, dass du möglichst nicht an die originalen URLs drankommst.
Und wenn das Porn-Seiten kann, dann kann das so ziemlich wie jede andere Seite wahrscheinlich auch.
Kann jemand helfen mit C++? Eine Funktion laut Images hatte 17 und jetzt 18 Inhalte.
What? Ich verstehe kein Worte.
Vielleicht sind es jetzt einfach 18 anstatt 17 Bilder.
So, AI. AI. Ne, Crypto. Cryptocurrency.
AI. AI.
Data Frames Powered by a Multi-Threaded Vectorized Query Engine.
Leute, wenn ihr diesen Satz lest, versteht ihr dann, was es ist?
Checkt irgendjemand, was es ist?
Polar is POC, sagt da Friedrich Merz. Friedrich Merz ist bekannt dafür, dass der Rust-Fan ist.
Was genau soll das sein?
Ich verstehe null anhand von diesem Satz, was das sein soll.
Ist das Art Link?
Ist das paralleles Link in Rust?
Oder was ist das?
Sieht ein bisschen so aus.
SQ... Okay, ich habe absolut nicht den Hauch einer Ahnung davon, was das sein soll.
AI. Warum wird AI geskippt?
Weil es einen nur noch erschlägt auf GitHub.
AI. AI.
Ah, was ist denn das hier?
Ich bin mir nicht so sicher, ob ich mich trauen soll, das aufzumachen.
Ach, man kann quasi Original-Sachen translaten in andere Sprachen, oder was?
Hm, verstehe, verstehe. Aha, aha.
Nice. Ich mache die Seite jetzt, die Original-Seite, nicht auf.
Weil ich nicht weiß, was mich da erwartet, wenn ich die öffne.
Die Bilder sind schon sehr sketchy.
Naja, nicht wirklich mehr sketchy als Pool-Streams auf Twitch, oder?
Also, da sind Pool-Streams nur wirklich...
...eigentlich noch mehr Toss, ohne Toss zu sein.
Okay, jetzt wissen wir, was auf GitHub trendet diese Woche.
So wirklich viel Spannendes war ja nicht dabei.
Pool-Streams sind auch ziemlich sketchy, das stimmt.
Habe ich jetzt vorhin schon rebooted, oder nicht?
Ich glaube, ich hatte rebooted. Ich reboote nochmal.
Ich glaube, ich habe genug rebooten.
Leute, ich war bei meinem Vater am Samstagvormittag,
weil er mir erzählt hat, sein Computer ist kaputt.
Habe ich mir gedacht, ach komm, lass mal gucken.
Das ist mein alter Computer, den habe ich dem quasi vermacht.
Also, mein vorletzter, der Xeon Desktop.
Der tut ja immer noch.
Da hatte ich einfach einmal frisch Windows 11 draufgeklatscht,
vorbeigebracht.
Mittlerweile ist er natürlich nicht mehr so frisch Windows 11 drauf,
sondern, Leute, der hat so einen Scheiß installiert alles.
Ihr könnt euch das nicht vorstellen, was für ein Scheiß da alles drauf war.
PC Cleaner 2025.
Irgendwelche komischen Internet-Speed-Tests.
Der Avira, nee, nicht Avira...
Wie heißen die anderen? Nicht Avira.
Avast-Browser? Irgendeinen Antivirus-Browser hat der.
Avast-Browser.
Und wirklich, es war so viel Scheiße drauf.
Irgendwas mit A.
Es könnte schon Avast gewesen sein.
Gibt es sowas wie Avast Security Browser?
Gibt es sowas?
Ja, den Scheiß hat er drauf installiert gehabt.
Avast Security Browser.
Ich wusste bis heute noch nicht mal, dass das Ding überhaupt existiert.
Felix, danke schön für den Sub.
Da war so viel Scheiße drauf.
20 Messenger.
Die Suche war umgestellt auf Yahoo mit RevLink von PC.
Nicht PC Cleaner.
Wie heißt das Ding? PC Helper?
Nee, PC Cleaner?
Gibt es was, was PC Cleaner heißt?
PC Cleaner?
PC Cleaner? Gibt es sowas?
Nee, das ist CC Cleaner.
Helpsoft! PC Cleaner!
Das war da drauf!
Ey, so ein Scheiß, Mann!
Das war so vollgerotzt mit Dreck, der Rechner.
Ganz, ganz grausam.
Zumindest...
Also, der Rechner ging selbstverständlich noch wunderbar.
Was nicht mehr ging, war sein Monitor.
Der Monitor hat irgendwie den Geist aufgegeben.
Das dachte ich mir aber schon.
Deswegen habe ich einen neuen Monitor mitgebracht.
Hab den Monitor angeschlossen und dann ist mir aufgefallen,
dass die Grafikkarte nicht mehr richtig funktioniert.
Das Ding lief nur mit Windows Basic Grafiktreibern und 1280x1024.
Rechner von meinem Vater.
Muss ich euch mal vorstellen.
Und dann habe ich mir gedacht, komm, easy, easy.
Ich installiere einfach von der AMD-Webseite
die neuesten Treiber und gut ist.
Und...
Das ging nicht.
Der AMD-Installer meinte die ganze Zeit, Fehler beim Hardware installieren.
Und ich wette mit euch, das liegt daran, weil da so viel Security...
Also, Scareware-Security-Scheiß im Hintergrund läuft,
was der sich mittlerweile alles installiert hat,
dass die Windows-11-Installation einfach schlicht und greifend kaputt ist.
Dazu kommt, dass wenn...
Also, als der Rechner nicht mehr funktioniert hat,
hat er den Rechner mehrfach, also irgendwie gefühlt,
zehnmal im Booten resettet, neu gestartet, resettet, neu gestartet.
Dass Windows da nicht so scharf drauf ist, weiß man ja auch.
Das einzige, was ich runtergeschmissen habe, ist PC Cleaner.
Der Rest war mir einfach zu viel, da jetzt zu suchen.
Und ich habe ihm gesagt, weißt du was?
Ich...
Ich muss das neu installieren und das ordentlich machen.
Aber das mache ich heute nicht.
Das dauert drei Stunden, bis wir das alles wieder eingerichtet haben.
Da habe ich heute echt keinen Nerv drauf.
Und außerdem müssen wir deine Sachen erstmal backuppen.
Ich habe keinen USB-Stick dabei und so.
Das können wir heute nicht machen.
Ich muss mir das mal überlegen.
Du musst jetzt ein paar Tage mit deinem Rechner auskommen, so wie er ist.
Basic, Grafiktreiber und so.
Ins Internet kannst du ja noch.
Und mit deinen 26-jährigen Mädels aus der Karibik,
muss ich es mal vorstellen.
Mein Vater, das habe ich euch schon mal erzählt.
Mein Vater ist 76, glaube ich.
76.
Und er hat angeblich eine Freundin, die ist 26.
Wobei man sagen muss, der hat ja nicht wirklich eine Freundin.
Der hat irgendeine Bekannte in der Karibik.
In der Dominikanischen Republik.
Die ihn wahrscheinlich ein bisschen ausnimmt mit Geld.
Wo er monatlich Geld hinüberweist, damit die ihm schöne Augen macht.
Doch, doch, der schickt ihr Geld.
Natürlich schickt er ihr Geld, Mann.
Meinst du, eine 26-Jährige aus der Karibik
gibt sich mit einem 76-jährigen alten deutschen Typ ab?
Wenn er nicht Geld...
Und mein Vater ist fest davon überzeugt...
Ja, das denke ich mir auch.
Scammer getting scammed.
Doch, doch, doch, da steckt wirklich eine Frau dahinter.
Da war die nämlich auch schon besuchen.
Also, ich glaube, das ist Scam.
Aber ich glaube, das ist nicht so ein...
Nee, ich glaube, das ist kein klassischer Roman-Scam.
Ich glaube, das ist so eine Geschichte, so ein Zwischending
aus Roman-Scam und Prostitution, vermute ich mal.
Also sprich, der ist ja da auch schon...
Der war ja dort auch schon
und hat die besucht und alles.
Zumindest, was auch immer.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was mein Vater da treibt.
Ich weiß auch nicht, warum man als 74-Jähriger
eine 26-jährige Freundin aus der Karibik braucht.
Whatever.
Der kann seine Rente auch ausgeben, wofür er will.
Ich habe ihm das schon ein paar Mal gesagt, dass...
Der ist ja auch...
Also, ich habe ihm schon ein paar Mal gesagt,
dass wenn er da kein Geld mehr überweisen würde,
die halt nichts von ihm wissen will
und er ist halt der Meinung, doch, doch,
wie geht es da...
Die sind da anders drauf als deutsche Frauen.
Ach, keine Ahnung.
Der ist alt, aber halt immer noch...
Ja, scharf auf knackige Weiber, ja.
Also, naja.
Zumindest, er glaubt halt nicht, dass es ein Scam ist
und sollte halt...
Soll er seine Rente...
Mehr als sagen kann man es ihm nicht.
Ich kann es ihm nicht ausgeben.
Ich war letztens mit ihm zusammen eingeloggt
in seinem PayPal-Account.
Ja, ey, wenn das bei mir mit 76 noch alles funktioniert,
bin ich auch happy.
Zumindest...
Ich war letztens mit ihm zusammen
in seinem PayPal-Account eingeloggt,
weil er da irgendwie Probleme hatte.
Da habe ich gesehen, es ist nicht so,
dass der da ultra viel hinüberweist.
Der überweist da immer mal wieder
so alle in der Woche 50 Euro
oder alle zwei Wochen mal 110 Euro.
Der überweist da schon konstant was hin,
aber es ist nicht so, als überweist er da
seine komplette Rente jedes Mal hin.
Man darf aber nicht vergessen,
in der Karibik sind glaube ich 50 Euro die Woche
auch schon eine super nice Zu...
Wie soll man sagen?
Zugewinn.
Und ich persönlich gehe auch davon aus,
dass er nicht der einzige deutsche Rentner ist,
dem die da schöne Augen machen.
Meine Vermutung ist,
das ist halt irgendein System dahinter.
Was kriegt der von ihr?
Die chatten und die telefonieren
und die, weiß ich nicht, ob die Discord oder Skype
oder was auch immer verwenden.
Und da fährt er auch ab und zu mal hin.
Weiß ich, wann das letzte Mal war,
vor einem Dreivierteljahr oder so,
war der ja in der Karibik auch.
Ist ja auch wurscht.
Soll er mit seiner Kohle machen?
Zumindest haben sie ihm ja auch
das letzte Mal ja irgendwie Geld geklaut
und alles und ach, keine Ahnung.
Meine Güte, ey.
Aber der ist unbelehrbar, was das angeht.
Ist das nicht einfach Onlyfans?
Ey, mir wäre es lieber,
der wäre auf Onlyfans.
Das ist garantiert Business, ja.
Zumindest habe ich halt zu ihm gesagt,
ey, wir können das jetzt nicht neu installieren,
das dauert wieder ewig.
Da hat er auch gesagt,
ich soll einfach alles platt machen.
Da habe ich gemeint,
ich mache nicht deinen kompletten Rechner platt.
Wenn überhaupt,
dann will ich schriftlich von dir haben,
dass du dich da auch noch in der Woche daran erinnerst,
dass du nichts von deinen Daten haben willst.
Das machen wir nicht.
Ich komme irgendwie an Ostern mal vorbei
mit einem USB-Stick,
dann machen wir ein Backup
und so lange muss die jetzt halt
mit der verkackten Windows-Installation auskommen.
Du hast jetzt wenigstens
einen Monitor wieder, der funktioniert,
hast zwar nicht die volle Auflösung,
du kannst nicht mit dem Rechner arbeiten,
aber musst jetzt halt mal aushalten.
Ich meine, ich habe es nicht kaputt gemacht,
hast es selbst kaputt gemacht,
jetzt musst du auch noch ein paar bisschen warten,
bis Ostern, dass ich vorbeikommen kann.
Und das machen wir.
Ja, Backup. Der hat nicht viel drauf,
95 Gigabyte.
Da nehme ich einen USB-Stick mit,
kopiere das rüber und dann ist gut.
So, da habe ich gesagt,
okay, also Rechner geht wieder,
Monitor geht, es ist genauso kacke wie vorher,
ich habe nur den Monitor gewechselt,
wenn du mir im Nachhinein erzählst,
ich hätte irgendwie den Rechner kaputt gemacht oder so.
Rentner erzählen ja viel, wenn der Tag lang ist.
Es ist genauso kacke wie vorher,
nur dass du wieder einen Monitor hast, der funktioniert.
Okay, dann bin ich abgehauen
und habe mir gestern,
gestern Mittag habe ich mir überlegt,
okay, doch, gestern habe ich mir überlegt,
ich gebe dem temporär meinen Mini-PC,
den ich mir als Emulator-Rechner gekauft habe.
Ich habe doch hier so einen,
ich habe doch hier so einen Mini-PC gekauft.
Ja, so einen Mini-PC habe ich mir doch hier gekauft
und ich dachte mir, ich gebe den dem temporär.
Ich installiere einfach Linux Mint drauf auf der zweiten Platte.
Da sind ja zwei Platten drin,
da muss ich meinen Emulator-Kram noch nicht mal runterschmeißen.
Ich installiere den einfach auf der zweiten Platte Linux Mint
und bringe den dem vorbei an Ostern
und nehme den anderen Rechner einfach wieder mit
und sage, weißt du was, ich brauche jetzt eine Weile,
bis ich den repariert habe.
In der Zwischenzeit kannst du das hier
mit dem PC verwenden.
Das ist zwar kein Windows, aber du kommst drauf.
Ich habe TeamViewer draufgehauen.
Ich habe sogar mal RustDesk ausprobiert,
aber RustDesk ist irgendwie noch nicht so feature-complete wie TeamViewer.
Ich habe TeamViewer draufgehauen und das registriert,
dass ich remote theoretisch sogar draufgucken könnte, wenn was ist
und dachte mir so, ey, was, was,
Ostern bringst du ihm das vorbei, nimmst den anderen mit.
Aber ruft er mich gestern an, Archilux, nein,
Linux Mint mit Cinnamon habe ich draufgepackt.
Ich habe auch nichts groß drauf konfiguriert,
wie gesagt, außer TeamViewer draufgehauen
und im Firefox uBlock Origin installiert, das ist alles.
Also es hat nicht lange gedauert.
So, und, ja, gute Frage.
Den Startbutton mit Rechtsklick entfernen kann,
ja, ich habe immer noch TeamViewer drauf,
ich kann ihm das wieder hinbiegen.
Ich dachte mir so, ich stelle ihm das hin,
der benutzt eh nur seinen Browser
und da kann er auch nichts kaputt machen großartig.
Zumindest ruft er mich dann gestern Mittag an,
müsst ihr euch mal vorstellen, ja,
ich fahre da hin, bringe ihm einen neuen Monitor,
gucke mir das an, installiere ihm eine Linux-Kiste
und da sieht man mal wieder,
Boomern, beziehungsweise, nein,
Noobs helfen mit PC-Support ist einfach ein,
wie nennt man das, ein sehr undankbarer Job.
Er hat mich gestern Mittag angerufen,
hat gemeint, er ist sehr enttäuscht von mir,
ihr müsst euch mal vorstellen, er ist sehr enttäuscht von mir,
dass ich ihn jetzt einfach mit dem kaputten Rechner hier habe sitzen lassen
und er wird sich jetzt einen neuen Computer online selbst kaufen
und sich jemanden suchen, der ihm das installiert.
Okay, da wollte ich mich erst mal aufregen
und habe ihn angeschissen, dass er seinen Rechner so versaut hat
und es in zwei Monaten eh wieder das Gleiche ist,
aber soll er machen?
Kein Support mehr von mir.
Dann habe ich nichts mehr mit zu tun.
Also ich habe gesagt, okay, mach, kauf dir das,
wenn du meinst, das ist besser.
In zwei Monaten hast du das Ding auch kaputt gemacht,
aber nicht mein Problem.
Und das war's.
Es ist schon etwas frech, wie er das gesagt hat.
Ja, Chad, ist es, ist es.
Ist es.
Das Problem ist, mein Vater ist jemand,
der denkt, sobald du ein-, zweimal was für ihn gemacht hast,
hat er ein Recht da drauf
und darf sich dann aufregen, wenn du was nicht machst.
Und das geht mir eh schon auf den Sack,
aber eh, ohne Scheiß, ich weiß eh, wie das laufen wird.
Ich weiß genau, was ist.
Ich weiß, es gibt zwei, es gibt zwei Szenarien.
Entweder der ruft mich nächste Woche an und fragt,
wann kommst du denn eigentlich vorbei und guckst dir nochmal
meinen Computer an, so als wäre nichts gewesen.
Oder er kauft sich wirklich einen neuen Computer
und dann ist er in zwei Monaten im Arsch und fragt,
kannst du mal nach meinem PC gucken?
Ja, ja, ja, irgendwie, irgendwie sowas.
Das Einzige, ohne Mist, das Einzige, was man machen könnte,
ist wirklich einfach ein halbes Jahr weder auf E-Mails
noch auf Telefon antworten.
Dass er mit dem, dass er mit dem Scheiß mal klarkommt.
Das Gute ist, er hat kein Auto.
Er kann nicht, er kann nicht, er kann nicht einfach vor der Tür stehen.
Wahrscheinlich helfe ich ihm am Ende trotzdem.
Ich bin, ihr müsst wissen, ich habe euch das ja schon ein paar Mal erzählt,
ich bin der Einzige, der mit meinem Vater noch redet.
Da hat er noch mehr Kinder.
Der hat drei Kinder, von denen man weiß.
Eins davon bin ich.
Der hat noch zwei andere.
Wie gesagt, insgesamt drei, von denen man weiß.
Ich könnte mir durchaus vorstellen, dass der noch mehr hat.
Außerdem lügt er wie gedruckt, denkt sich laufend
irgendwelche komischen Storys aus.
Das kommt ja auch noch dabei.
Er hat in seinem Leben ultra viele Leute gescampt.
Weswegen er sogar seinen Nachnamen geändert hat,
dass man ihn nicht mehr findet.
Er hat den Nachnamen geändert, hat eine Privatinsolvenz gemacht,
dass er die Schulden los ist.
Und dass ihn die Leute, die er gescampt hat, nicht mehr finden.
Könnt ihr euch schon vorstellen, was da gelaufen ist?
Hast du Geschwister? Nein, nein.
Ich habe nur halbe Geschwister.
Die anderen Kinder, die er hat, sind nicht von meiner Mutter.
Aber weder von seinen anderen Kindern noch von seiner Familie
noch von seinen Ex-Frauen irgendjemand oder von seinen Freunden,
die er mal hatte, noch irgendjemand will was von ihm wissen.
Niemand. Niemand redet mehr mit ihm.
Niemand kümmert sich um ihn.
Der hat ja quasi sein ganzes Leben darauf hingearbeitet,
dass das so ist.
Ich bin der Einzige, der noch ab und zu mit ihm hat telefoniert.
Und das Problem ist halt auch, mittlerweile,
also der war schon immer sehr schwierig,
hat immer schon immer gerne rumgeschrien, Sachen rumgeschmissen
und sich bei allen Leuten unbeliebt gemacht.
Hat auch schon immer gerne Leute gescampt.
Er hat auch schon immer gerne Sachen erzählt, die nicht stimmen.
Jetzt kommt aber noch dazu, dass er alt ist und nicht mehr durchblickt.
Von meinem Vater habe ich nichts geerbt.
Also erstens, er lebt noch, von dem habe ich nichts geerbt.
Und mein Vater hat nichts, was er mir vererben kann.
Das Einzige, was er mir vererben wird, sind Schulden.
Und ich werde das auch nicht annehmen.
Wie gesagt, es will keiner mehr was von ihm wissen.
Dazu kommt jetzt noch, dass er alt ist
und jetzt nicht nur alles das macht, was er früher immer gemacht hat,
plus, dass er jetzt ein bisschen verwirrt ist dadurch, dass er alt war.
Ich meine, er hatte zwei Herzinfarkte schon
und hat Nierenprobleme, war im Krankenhaus und alles.
Und ich bin übrigens da, ich habe ihn aus dem Krankenhaus abgeholt.
Niemand anderes von irgendwem, der ihn kennt,
hat ihn aus dem Krankenhaus abgeholt nach einem Herzinfarkt.
Ja, ist es auch. Deswegen fällt er ja auch auf so Scammer,
Scamweiber aus der Karibik rein. 100 pro, daran liegt es auch.
Zumindest, jetzt kommt noch dazu, dass er ein bisschen verwirrt ist,
weil er älter ist und dass er immer mehr, also noch krasser rumlügt
als früher. Die Story mit der Entführung habe ich euch schon erzählt,
die keine Entführung war, oder? Habe ich euch die schon mal erzählt?
Ich glaube schon, aber ganz kurz, nur mal für alle, die es nicht wissen.
Mein Vater hat mich eines Tages angeschrieben und meinte,
er ist in der Karibik und er wurde entführt.
Und er braucht jetzt 500 Euro Lösegeld.
Das ist, ohne Scheiß, es ist kein Witz. Das hat er so geschrieben.
Ich schmücke das nicht aus und ich übertreibe das nicht.
Das hat er eins zu eins so geschrieben.
Da denke ich mir so, okay, ich kenne ja meinen Vater.
Das heißt, ich war erst mal schon sehr misstrauisch, dass das stimmt.
Weil der immer Mist erzählt.
Klingt wie ein Scammer, nur dass es dein Vater ist.
Ja, genau. Ja, ist es, ja.
Der Witz ist, immer wenn er erzählt, sagt er, ich habe sie alle beschissen,
aber meine Familie habe ich nie beschissen.
Na ja, da kann man sich jetzt drüber streiten.
Ich gehe davon aus, dass er mich tatsächlich nicht absichtlich beschissen hat.
Aber der hat ja auch schon mal random einen Internetanschluss in Hamburg
auf meinen Namen bestellt.
Auf einmal habe ich von der Telekom einen Brief gekriegt.
Mein Internetanschluss in Hamburg ist nicht bezahlt.
Sie wollen das Geld.
Und ich denke mir so, hä? Ich habe einen Internetanschluss in Hamburg?
Seit wann habe ich den denn?
Bis ich dann draufgekommen bin, mein Vater,
mein Vater hat einen Internetanschluss abgeschlossen in Hamburg auf meinen Namen.
Und noch besser, der hat meine Unterschrift gefakt oder irgendwas.
Ich weiß nicht, wie er den Vertrag unterschrieben hat.
Ich habe den nicht unterschrieben.
Also, der Scammer, zumindest kommen wir zu der Geschichte.
Er hat mir eine E-Mail geschrieben, er wurde entführt in der Karibik
und braucht 500 Euro Lösegeld.
Und da dachte ich mir schon, okay, ich kenne meinen Vater,
das stimmt bestimmt nicht.
Aber was ist denn da jetzt?
So, und die Wahrheit war, er wurde nicht entführt.
Die Wahrheit war, er ist in der Karibik in ein Krankenhaus gegangen,
hat sich dort behandeln lassen und wollte abhauen,
ohne zu bezahlen.
Und da haben die dann gesagt, Herr Max Papa,
Sie bleiben jetzt mal schön hier,
bis Sie die 500-Euro-Rechnung bezahlt haben.
Weil wenn wir Sie jetzt hier rauslassen, dann sehen wir die 500 Euro ja nie.
Das Problem für ihn war nur, er hatte keine 500 Euro.
Und wisst ihr, da sieht man mal schon wieder, dass der sie nicht mehr alle hat.
Hätte der mir geschrieben, ja, hätte der mir geschrieben, Max,
ich sitze in der Karibik fest, weil ich im Krankenhaus war.
Ich muss eine Rechnung von 500 Euro bezahlen,
sonst lassen die mich hier nicht weg.
Habe ich aber gerade nicht, kannst du mir helfen?
Flucht der Karibik, ja.
Da hätte ich ihm das auch, dann hätte ich ihm natürlich,
ich hätte die Rechnung bezahlt und gut wäre gewesen, ja.
Aber er hat gedacht, er muss irgendwie sich eine komische
Entführungsstory ausdenken, die nicht stimmt.
Und das ist halt das Ding, der könnte eigentlich
bei den meisten Sachen näher bei der Wahrheit bleiben
und man würde ihm trotzdem helfen, aber dadurch,
dass der sich dann so krasse Sachen ausdenkt oder einen anlügt,
glaubst du ihm nichts mehr, du glaubst ihm kein Wort.
Und das ist halt das Ding, du kannst ihm nichts glauben.
Naja, also wie gesagt, ich weiß nicht, wie ich jetzt darauf gekommen bin,
zumindest, es ist echter Wahnsinn.
Ich glaube, viele Leute haben anstrengende Eltern, ja.
Aber ich glaube, mit meinem Vater habe ich schon echt eine Ausnahmeform
von anstrengenden Eltern.
Mein Vater hat einfach das Scammer-Crime-Set, hat er auch, hat er auch.
Mein Vater ist ein Scammer durch und durch.
Der bezahlt ja aus Prinzip auch keine Rechnung.
Ich habe letztens dem seinen Briefkasten ausgeleert
und ohne Scheiß, da kam ein Stapel, wenn ihr so eine Faust macht, ja,
so dick, ja, das ist jetzt eine Blödsache,
so dick wie der Arm kam da ein Stapel an Briefen
und das waren alles irgendwelche Inkassoschreiben von irgendwelchen Dingern,
woran irgendwo mal was gekauft hat, nicht bezahlt hat.
Und er sagt zu mir, ach, schmeiß die Dinger weg, ich mach die eh nicht auf
und bezahlen du auch nichts.
Weil, und jetzt kommt die Erklärung, bezahlen tut er nichts, weil,
das ist aber wortwörtlich, Zitat, das geht ja gegen seine Prinzipien, was zu bezahlen.
Da wisst ihr schon Bescheid, oder?
Der Kerl, Alter.
Ach ja, und mal davon abgesehen, ich hab mal streng genommen auch keinerlei Verpflichtung,
nur weil es mein Vater ist, dort für den überhaupt irgendwas zu machen, ja.
Es ist jetzt nicht so, als hätte der sich groß um mich gekümmert,
beziehungsweise als wäre er seinen Pflichten nachgekommen.
Der hat meine Mutter sitzen lassen, wo ich, frag mich nicht, 1, 2 Jahre alt war
und hat so gut wie nie Unterhalt bezahlt.
Bis, bis ich dann erwachsen war.
Also eigentlich, eigentlich hat er nichts gemacht.
Im Prinzip ist er abgehauen.
Und hat sich dann nicht drum, obwohl der mehr als genug Geld hat damals,
weil damals hatte er noch sein Scambusiness in Frankfurt am Start.
Seine Partnervermittlungsagentur.
Ich meine, das, was heute im Internet gemacht wird und auch Leute gescampt wird,
hat er damals offline gemacht.
Hat auch ganz viele Leute gescampt, allerdings legal.
Der hat die legal gescampt.
Die haben halt Verträge unterschrieben, wo man sich fragt.
Ihr müsst euch vorstellen, mein Vater, der, den haben sie ja angezeigt,
da stand er sogar vor Gericht wegen dieser ganzen Geschichte, die er da abgezogen hat.
Der wurde freigesprochen.
Also, muss sagen, offiziell ist mein Vater kein verurteilter Scammer oder so.
Der wurde freigesprochen, weil er so gute Verträge gemacht hat.
Und es muss wohl in der Verhandlung so gewesen sein, dass einer der, ich weiß nicht,
ob es der Richter war oder sonst was.
Der muss eine der Klientinnen damals wohl wirklich wortwörtlich gefragt haben,
wie kann man so einen Vertrag unterschreiben?
Es war quasi so der komplette Freibrief, der Vertrag, den die da unterschrieben haben.
Also, da konnten sie eben keinen Strick draus drehen.
Der ist freigesprochen.
Aber der hat schon das krasse Scammer-Mindset.
Naja, gut. Okay.
Ja, und damals hat er richtig fett Kohle verdient, ja.
Ihr müsst euch vorstellen, das muss so im Dreh gewesen sein, 1990 rum.
1980, also ich bin 1984 geboren.
Das muss so 1988, 89, 90, 91, 92, 93 rum gewesen sein.
So in den paar Jahren.
Da hat der Typ richtig krass Kohle gemacht.
Der hatte mehrere zehntausend, ich wollte gerade sagen Euro,
waren es ja damals noch nicht.
Der hat mehrere zehntausend Euro, mehrere zehntausend Mark im Monat
auf der hohen Kante gehabt durch sein Scambusiness.
Der hätte mehr als genug Geld gehabt, Unterhalt zu bezahlen.
Hat er aber nicht gemacht.
Moin.
Und die Aussage meiner Mutter damals gegenüber war,
das hatte mir, das hatte mir, klingt sehr verantwortungslos.
Ja, er ist die Verantwortungslosigkeit in Person.
Das heißt, Scam und Verantwortungslosigkeit in Person ist er.
Meiner Mutter hat er damals wortwörtlich gesagt, er kann erst Unterhalt bezahlen,
nachdem er zehntausend Mark im Monat für sich hat.
Das muss man sich mal vorstellen, ja.
Du hast deine Ex-Frau sitzen lassen mit dem Kind und sagst, du kannst keinen Unterhalt bezahlen.
Du kannst erst Unterhalt bezahlen, wenn du mindestens zehntausend Mark für dich im Monat hast.
Allein schon, allein schon, dass du auf so eine Aussage kommst.
Der hat das richtige Mindset am Start gehabt.
Und daraufhin ist meine Mutter ja damals zum, frag mich nicht, zum Amt, zur Polizei,
oder ich weiß es nicht, was das war.
Und die haben dann quasi das bezahlt für den in Vorkasse
und haben dann versucht, das Geld von dem quasi zu fenden, sozusagen.
Ich weiß nicht, wie man dieses Verfahren nennt.
Und da hat er sich dann auch versucht,
quasi der Sache zu entziehen und so und hat einfach nichts bezahlt.
Alter, ganz, ganz grausam.
Heute, ohne Scheiß, wenn mein Vater heute in dem Alter wäre wie damals,
wo er sein Business am Start hatte, der hätte so ein Komm-in-die-Gruppe-Ding.
Der hätte heute Komm-in-die-Gruppe- und Motivations-Business-Coaching hätte der heute.
Garantiert.
Mein Vater ist genau so ein Typ, der heute so ein Business-Coaching machen würde.
Daku, dankeschön für den Sub.
So, jetzt habe ich aber lang genug über meinen Vater und Verwandtschaft und mich erzählt.
Wir gucken uns mal ein paar YouTube-Videos an, um die Stimmung aufzunehmen.
Heute, der hätte garantiert Komm-in-die-Gruppe hätte der.
Schlauer Hase Insi.
Mein Vater hat den Insi-Modus durch.
Der hat eine Privatinsolvenz gemacht vor ein paar Jahren.
Nachdem er witzigerweise seinen Nachnamen geändert hat,
dass ihn die Leute von früher nicht mehr finden.
Also, da wisst ihr schon Bescheid, was da Sache ist, ja?
Wieso?
Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Der hat drei Kinder.
Das heißt nicht, dass der für drei Kinder Unterhalt bezahlt hätte.
Für mich hat er keinen Unterhalt bezahlt.
Und für seine anderen zwei Kinder hat er garantiert, hundertprozentig,
auch keinen Unterhalt bezahlt.
Namensänderung Privatinsolvenz.
Könnt ihr euch mal vorstellen.
Mein Vater ist der klassische Komm-in-die-Gruppe-Mindset-Lifestyle-Coach von heute.
Nur, dass es damals halt ein anderes Business war.
Aber heute würde der exakt sowas machen.
Kennst du die anderen Geschwister?
Welche? Meine Halbgeschwister?
Nee, die kenn ich nicht.
Also, ich kenn die von Bildern und so.
Und die kennen mich auch von irgendwelchen Fotos und so.
Aber wir hatten nie großartige, wie soll ich sagen, Ambitionen, uns kennenzulernen.
Da kann ApoRed definitiv noch was lernen.
Der hat das schon durchgespielt.
Da gab's ApoRed noch nicht.
Gut, also, was gucken wir uns denn jetzt mal an?
Brainchips.
Stimmt, was ist da eigentlich draus geworden?
Was haben wir denn hier sonst noch?
Was ist das?
Fuck.
Polizeieinstellungstest.
Okay, Leute.
Sekunde, Sekunde, Sekunde.
Wir hatten jetzt so viel Low-Brain-Kontext, wir brauchen jetzt High-IQ-Kontext.
Okay, Polizeieinstellungstest.
Geht nur 2 Minuten 23, kann nicht so kompliziert sein.
Okay.
Generelles und Aufgabe.
Okay, Chat, jetzt will ich hier sehen von euch, was die ganzen Subscriptions gebracht haben.
Wie hoch der Chat-IQ ist.
Wenn wir nicht mindestens 90% die richtige Antwort hier im Chat kriegen,
dann muss ich meinen Channel löschen.
Nee, lieber nicht.
Dann bauten die Leute absichtlich falsch.
Dann passiert nichts, außer dass ihr Low-IQ seid.
Okay, passt mal auf.
Wir lassen uns jetzt mal die Aufgabe erklären.
Hier haben wir die Aufgabe.
Du sollst dir also aus den gegebenen Figuren einmal entscheiden, welche Figur A, B, C oder D das Fragezeichen sinnvoll ersetzt.
Ich geb dir ein bisschen Zeit, damit du dieses Video pausieren kannst.
Easy, easy, easy.
Okay, Umfrage.
Umfrage.
Was ist richtig?
A, B, C, D.
Ihr könnt euch das kurz überlegen.
Das ist easy as fuck.
Abstimmung, Leute.
Ich bin mal gespannt.
Du siehst D nicht?
Ja, Moment.
Ja, YouTube sackt ein bisschen mit dem Overlay.
D ist so ein Pac-Man.
A, B, C, D.
Okay, was haben wir?
Manche sagen A, manche sagen C.
Mehrheit sagt D.
Keiner sagt B.
Ach, der Chat war davor.
Okay.
Alles klar.
Okay, Leute.
Ich gehe mit euch d'accord.
Ich denke auch, dass es D ist, weil das Quadrat hier oder das Rechteck, ist auch egal, das wird quasi zur Hälfte gekippt nach rechts.
Und wenn man diesen halboffenen oder diesen vierteloffenen Kreis zur Hälfte nach rechts kippt, dann kommt D raus.
Ah, Soso, du hast recht.
Da habe ich gar nicht dran gedacht.
Ja, ihr habt, Chat, Chat, ihr habt recht.
Ja, ihr habt recht.
Es könnte genauso gut nach links gekippt sein.
Da habe ich gar nicht dran gedacht, ja.
Macht das einen Unterschied?
Was ist mit dem Abo?
Oh, das müssen wir gleich gucken.
Ja, ihr habt recht.
Wir wissen nicht, ob links rum oder rechts rum.
Aber nichtsdestotrotz, es wird auf jeden Fall nur halb gekippt.
Und halb gekippt kann nicht das sein, egal wie du es drehst und wendest.
Es kann nicht das sein, nicht das, es kann eigentlich nur D sein.
Aber muss es eine 45 Grad Drehung sein?
Naja, am meisten sind ja diese Aufgaben, finde das untere, was entsprechend zu dem oberen passt.
Also, ich weiß nicht, ob es 45 Grad sind exakt, aber es sieht halt halb gekippt aus.
Oder zur Hälfte gekippt.
Egal, gucken wir mal, was rauskommt.
Also, generell ist es bei diesen Aufgaben so, du hast eine obere Reihe.
Ja, ich will einfach wissen, was rauskommt.
Da haben wir nämlich einen schwarzen Kreisausschnitt.
Und wenn wir genau das gleiche machen müssen wie oben, bedeutet das, okay, da muss die gleiche Figur hin, aber diese Figur muss einfach...
Vielleicht wurde es auch 315 Grad nach links gedreht.
Das kann sein, aber dann würde keines passen von den hier unten.
Also, es kann eigentlich nur D sein.
Einfach um 45 Grad gedreht werden.
Das bedeutet, wir suchen jetzt hier einen schwarzen Kreisausschnitt, der auch um 45 Grad gedreht ist.
Und wenn uns das einmal klar ist, dann wird schnell klar, dass D die einzig richtige Lösung ist.
Chat, ich bin begeistert von euch, ihr wisst Bescheid.
Kreisausschnitt A ist um 150 Grad gedreht.
Kreisausschnitt B ist um 90 Grad gedreht.
Ja, okay, blablabla.
Das hätte mich jetzt auch sehr gewundert, wenn das nicht D ist.
Wenn man solche Dinge hat, verkackt man es ja ab und zu.
Auch mal ganz gerne.
Aber das war obvious.
So, und was wollte ich mir noch angucken?
Warum dir jeder Scheiß im Abo vertickt wird.
Okay, die kurze Erklärung, ohne das Video zu gucken, ist, weil es mir Geld bringt.
Ja, Leute, Bewerbung Polizei ist raus, oder?
Ganz davon abgesehen, ich würde im Leben nicht bei der Polizei arbeiten wollen.
So.
Gucken wir uns das an.
Das passt ja wunderbar zum Stream.
Da habe ich mich am Anfang auch schon drüber beschwert.
Dass es für jeden Scheiß einen Abo braucht.
2013.
Im Headquarter des amerikanischen Softwarelegal Adobe.
Adobe.
Ich habe das früher immer Adobe ausgesprochen.
Aber die coolen Leute sprechen das natürlich Adobe aus.
Manche sagen auch Adobe.
Leute, Adobe, Adobe, Adobe.
Sagen die eigentlich offiziell, wie sie heißen?
Oder ist das Interpretationsraum?
Ich meine, Adobe ist ein sehr offizielles Unternehmen.
Es ist ein sehr offizielles Unternehmen.
Und es ist eine sehr kreative und sehr kreative Firma.
Und es herrscht Anspannung pur.
Es ist der wohl wichtigste Tag in der 31-jährigen Unternehmensgeschichte.
Denn an diesem Tag trifft Adobe eine radikal...
Musik im Hintergrund, Alter.
... entscheidung.
In Zukunft will das Unternehmen seine Produkte nicht mehr verkaufen,
sondern nur noch in einem monatlichen Abo anbieten.
In diesem Video erzählen wir euch die Story
von einem der riskantesten Business Moves der jüngeren Wirtschaftsgeschichte
und wie dieser die Welt für immer verändert hat.
Das hier ist Shantanu Narayan.
Amerikanische Tech-Medien bezeichnen ihn immer wieder als Genie.
2011 holt ihn sogar Barack Obama als Berater...
Ich kenne ihn nicht. Kanntet ihr den?
... in sein Team.
Er ist zu diesem Zeitpunkt seit sechs Jahren der CEO des Unternehmens
und damit auch Schlüsselfigur
in einer absolut verrückten Adobe-Story.
Okay, wait. Jetzt kann es vielleicht sein,
dass ihr noch nie von Adobe gehört habt.
Ein Produkt kennt ihr aber safe.
Photoshop.
Und zwar folgendes.
Ja, das ist Photoshop-Philip.
Er hat's nicht so mit Menschen,
aber er beherrscht Photoshop wie kein zweiter Photoshop-Philip.
Adobe ist das Unternehmen,
das hinter zum Beispiel Photoshop oder After Effects steckt.
Also genau die Programme,
ohne die ich so wichtige Dinge wie das hier
nicht machen könnte.
Adobe steht so ziemlich hinter jedem Programm,
mit dem Content produziert wird.
InDesign, After Effects, Premiere, Acrobat, Flash Player
und noch rund 50 weitere Programme hat Adobe 2013 im Sortiment.
Selbst dieses Video hier wurde nur mit Adobe-Programmen gemacht.
Grüße gehen raus an unsere Katharin Carey.
Mit Photoshop und Co. hat Adobe damals bereits richtig viel Kohle verdient.
Schaut mal.
Zwischen 2002 und 2012 ist der Umsatz des Unternehmens
mit einer Ausnahme jedes Jahr gewachsen.
2012 hat Adobe einen Umsatz von fast 5 Milliarden Dollar gemacht.
Und dann gehen Anfang der 10er Jahre auch noch Social-Media-Plattformen
wie Instagram, YouTube oder Pinterest komplett durch die Decke.
Also alles Plattformen, für die Bildbearbeitungssoftware
aka Photoshop gebraucht wird.
Kurz gesagt, Adobe sitzt 2012 mit seinen Programmen
auf einer Goldgrube.
Und das heißt in Zahlen, das Unternehmen macht 2012
einen fetten Gewinn von einer Milliarde Euro im Jahr.
Läuft also für Adobe.
Da lacht sich Apple ja kaputt.
Und zwar Shantanu Narayan.
Ihr erinnert euch, der CEO von Adobe.
Er ist sogar so unzufrieden, dass er das gesamte Geschäftsmodell
seiner Firma in Frage stellt.
Und das hat vor allem einen Grund.
Das ist ihm nicht Keck-Business genug.
Und zwar diese CD hier.
Es gibt zwei fette Probleme.
Das erste ist, sie war verdammt teuer.
Wer alle Programme von Adobe nutzen wollte,
musste für die CD etwa 2.000 Dollar auf den Tisch legen.
Vor allem Hobby-Fotografen haben sich damals also mindestens zweimal überlegt,
ob sie sich so ein riesen Investment leisten wollen.
Der zweite Grund, die waren einfach übel leicht zu kopieren.
Und an kopierten CDs verdient Adobe natürlich nichts.
Warum hat das Keck-Business im Hintergrund,
warum ist das nicht freigestellt, das Bild?
Aber ich glaube, wir brauchen eindeutig
Background-Removal-AI dafür jetzt.
Und drittens, naja, CDs waren halt damals schon ziemlich uncool.
Hoppla! Legt die CD ...
Ist ja gut, ey.
... den CDs, und zwar für immer.
Narayans Plan ...
Man hätte das ja auch einfach downloaden können ohne CD.
... will das Unternehmen seine Produkte nicht mehr verkaufen,
sondern verleihen.
Ja, die haben mit dem Scheiß angefangen, also.
Die waren's!
Neue Produktinnovationen werden ausschließlich
über Adobe Creative Cloud bereitgestellt.
Statt einmalig 2.000 Dollar müssen Adobe-Kunden
in Zukunft 50 Dollar im Monat für einen Zugang zu der Cloud zahlen.
Es ist eine Nachricht, die in der Business-Welt einschlägt ...
50 Euro ist auch schon ein Kratzelpreis.
Was kostet das aktuell?
Warum hat mir Noah Leidinger vom Podcast
Ohne Aktien wird schwer erklärt.
Doch ein Risiko war auch, dass dieses normale Geschäft
ja sehr gut gelaufen ist und auch sehr attraktive Margen hatte.
Und es hätte halt auch sein können, dass die Kunden sagen,
nee, wir wollen nicht so eine regelmäßige Gebühr haben.
Das, was Noah da sagt, heißt in anderen Worten,
Adobe-CEO Narayan setzt mit seiner Entscheidung die Zukunft
seiner 10.000 Mitarbeiter aufs Spiel.
Ja, als würde er sich für die Mitarbeiter interessieren.
... TechCrunch titelt deshalb Adobe Goes All In.
Und erst mal scheint es so, als wäre dieser Move
die dümmste Idee der Wirtschaftsgeschichte.
Denn kurz nach der Pressemitteilung sieht es so aus,
als ob der Move komplett nach hinten losgeht.
Denn die Kunden reagieren erst mal so.
Ja, das ist ja normal.
Es wird immer rumgeschrien erst mal und dann gewöhnt man sich dran
und dann geht es sogar noch weiter hoch.
Ich habe letztens gehört, dass World of Warcraft angeblich
wieder mehr Abonnenten hat als in der Zeit von vor ein paar Jahren,
wo sie so super krass am Start waren.
Natürlich ist das ein bisschen unfair zu vergleichen.
Heute ist Gaming viel, viel Mainstreamiger.
Und das Game ist sehr auf, wie soll man sagen,
so viel auf Missing Out und sowas ausgelegt.
Mehr als früher.
Aber die Stonks rollen.
Okay, ich sage es mal so.
Adobe's Kunden sind nicht gerade glücklich
mit der Umstellung aufs Abo-Modell.
Fast 50.000 Menschen unterschreiben sogar eine Petition,
dass Adobe die Umstellung wieder rückgängig machen soll.
Und zwar sofort.
In der Petition heißt es, Adobe beraubt kleine Unternehmen,
Freiberufler und den Durchschnittsverbraucher.
Und der US-amerikanische Star-Fotograf David Hobby
schreibt sogar, nichts für ungut, Adobe,
aber das fühlt sich an wie der größte Geldraub
in der Geschichte der Software.
Okay, what?
Der größte Geldraub der Geschichte?
Das hört sich erst mal nach einem ziemlich krassen Vorwurf an.
Über den müssen wir später noch mal sprechen.
Weniger emotional reagieren auf...
Die Leute waren damals einfach pepega.
Also Petitionen bringen überhaupt nichts.
Bob hätte mal wieder eine Army bilden müssen gegen Adobe.
Das hätte bestimmt funktioniert.
Auf jeden Fall die Investoren.
Die interessieren sich nur für die Zahlen.
Falls sich da noch irgendjemand dran erinnern kann.
Bob builds an Army.
Gegen was hat Bob noch mal die Army gebildet?
Google+.
Google+, oder?
Ja, ja, Google+.
Bob war gegen Google+.
Und die Zahlen brechen erst mal ein.
2012 hat Adobe ja noch einen fetten Gewinn von einer...
Bob hat langfristig gewonnen.
Aber nicht durch seine Army.
Bob hat durch Aussitzen und Unfähigkeit von Google gewonnen.
...Milliarde Dollar gemacht.
Ein Jahr später, also kurz nach der Umstellung auf das Abo-Modell,
bricht der Gewinn einfach um die Hälfte ein.
Für Noah Leidinger ist das aber auch kein großes Wunder.
Und erst mal muss man ja auch Geld in Marketing investieren,
um das neue Abo-Modell bekannt zu machen,
um Kunden zu überzeugen, dass sie da hinwechseln sollen.
Und das hat natürlich auch auf die Gewinnmargen gedrückt.
Was Noah damit meint, der Umstieg...
Und das erste halbe Jahr oder das erste Jahr
ist ja auch eine ganze Ecke günstiger als den Vollpreis zu bezahlen.
Und für ein Viertel des Vollpreises damals das Abo abschließen.
Das dauert natürlich...
Dafür ist es langfristig gesehen viel mehr Stonks.
Das Abo-Modell war verdammt teuer.
Denn neben teurem Marketing musste Adobe zum Beispiel auch viel Geld
in seine Creative Cloud investieren
und die eigenen Abteilungen umstrukturieren.
Das muss man auch...
Und da muss man wirklich auch mal den Hut vor denen ziehen.
Das scheinen sie ja ganz gut hinbekommen zu haben.
Ich habe kein Creative Cloud Abo,
deswegen kann ich das nicht aus erster Hand berichten.
Also erstens muss man diesen Move erst mal machen.
Und das muss dann auch funktionieren.
Weil stellt euch mal vor,
es hätte nicht nur diesen riesen Shitstorm gegeben am Anfang
so nach dem Motto Abo-Modell, alles scheiße und sonst wie.
Stellt euch mal vor, die hätten das umgestellt
und das Subscription Creative Cloud Abo hätte nicht richtig funktioniert.
Was meint ihr, wie groß dann das Geschrei gewesen wäre?
Aber davon hörst du ja so gut wie nichts.
Also das scheint ja echt ganz gut zu funktionieren.
In anderen Worten heißt das,
mit der Umstellung auf das Abo-Modell
ist Shontano Narayan eine ziemlich riskante Wette eingegangen.
Eine Wette, die sich auf zwei Worte herunterbrechen lässt.
Wiederkehrende Einnahmen.
Und auf diese wiederkehrenden Einnahmen setzt...
Er hat einfach das richtige High-Performer-Mindset am Start gehabt.
...narayan nun alles.
Top. Die Wette gilt.
Alle Rätsel über den abenteuerlichen Move von Adobe...
Nur einer behält komplett die Ruhe.
Es ist Shontano Narayan.
Denn der hat den Umsatz- und Gewinneinbruch,
den wir uns im letzten Kapitel angeschaut haben,
längst einkalkuliert.
Er glaubt fest an den Abo-Move.
Und naja, was soll ich sagen?
Schaut euch einfach mal die Zahlen an.
Den Umsatz von Adobe vor dem Abo-Move, den kennt ihr.
Was aber danach abgeht, ist einfach nur crazy.
Crazy?
Mit dem Abo-Modell hat sich der Umsatz von Adobe einfach verwirrt.
Stonks. Ultra-Stonks.
Das sind über 90% des Umsatzes aus den Abo-Einnahmen.
Hyper-Stonks.
Das seht ihr an den gelben Balken hier.
Narayans Wette ist also komplett aufgegangen.
Oh, diese Einspieler sind super cringe, Mann.
...die Adobe-Programme ja ungefähr 2000 Dollar gekostet.
Mit den Abos zahlen Kunden jetzt aber 50 Dollar im Monat
beziehungsweise 600 Dollar im Jahr.
Das heißt konkret, behält ein Kunde das Abo länger als vier Jahre,
dann verdient Adobe jetzt mehr mit ihm als mit den CDs.
Und?
Und diese Langzeit-Nutzer sind halt weg.
So, ich kauf mir das und benutze es dann zehn Jahre.
Man hat gesehen, dass nicht nur der Umsatz massiv gestiegen ist
von Adobe langfristig, sondern vor allem,
dass die Margen dann auch noch mal viel besser waren.
Was das in konkreten Zahlen heißt,
zeige ich euch noch mal an der Grafik von eben.
2022 hat Adobe mit Photoshop, InDesign und Co.
nämlich einfach mal einen Gewinn von 6 Milliarden Euro gemacht.
Also ungefähr sechsmal so viel wie noch 2012 zu CD-Zeiten.
Schon verrückt, oder?
In der Hölle konnte das Abo-Modell so krass einschlagen.
Das erzähle ich euch jetzt mal am Beispiel von meinem Kumpel Tommy.
Der Tommy ist nämlich seit kurzem Design-
Oh, das muss ich mir jetzt wieder angucken.
Eigentlich wissen wir doch schon ...
... ein Game-Changer und erobert von nun an die Welt.
Erfinder des Abo-Modells im Software-Bereich war übrigens nicht Adobe,
sondern eine ganz andere Firma, und zwar Salesforce.
Die verkaufen ...
Oh, nee!
... ihr Software aber ausschließlich an Unternehmen.
Nachdem Adobe ab 2013 bewiesen hat,
dass das Abo-Modell auch im Privatkundengeschäft funktioniert,
breitet sich der Abo-Hype in der gesamten Tech-Branche aus.
Microsoft Office, Zoom, Snowflake, Asana ...
Wait, Zoom?
Da kann man Abo für abschließen?
Ich bin der übelste Kack-Noob.
Das sagt mir was, was übrigens gar nicht mal Microsoft Office heißt.
Aber das ist zweitrangig.
Zoom kenne ich auch.
Ich meine, das sind ja auch irgendwie Snowflake und Asana.
Größte deutsche Softwareunternehmen SAP.
Mittlerweile setzen fast alle großen Softwarekonzerne auf Abo-Modelle.
In der Tech-Szene ist das Business-Konzept mittlerweile so ...
Gibt es eigentlich irgendjemand, der SAP mag, außer SAP Consultants?
Ich glaube, nicht mal SAP Consultants mögen SAP.
Ich glaube, die mögen die Kohle, die man damit machen kann.
Privat haben die aber auch keinen Bock drauf.
... stark verbreitet, dass es dort jetzt einen eigenen Namen hat.
Software as a Service.
Und dieses Modell ist so erfolgreich, dass gerade so ziemlich jede Branche auf den Hype mit aufspringt.
Spotify, Netflix und Amazon Prime werden die meisten von euch ja noch kennen.
Bei dir in der Firma mögen viele SAP und ABAP ...
Sind die noch ... haben die irgendwie geistig irgendwelche Probleme?
Oder ist das ... wie kommt's?
Ein Witz.
Bei Amazon haben sie sogar Windeln, Weine und sogar Blumensträuße im Abo vertickt.
Schon wild, oder?
Bei Amazon, wenn ich Katzenfutter bestellt habe oder Zahnpasta oder ...
Letztens hab ich Interdentalbürsten bestellt bei Amazon.
Also, das ist jetzt was, was nicht so oft gekauft wird hier, ja?
Talbürsten, sowas hab ich bestellt bei Amazon.
Äh ...
Was sind denn meine?
Was find ich?
Hier, sowas hier zum Beispiel, ja?
Cura ... Cura ... Cura ... Prox.
So, und wenn man die jetzt versucht zu kaufen bei Amazon, dann sagt Amazon ...
Möchten Sie das Ganze als Abo ...
Ah, okay, ich bin nicht eingeloggt, ja?
Amazon sagt, möchten Sie das jetzt als Abo bestellen?
Darf ich auch ... wie jetzt?
Zahnbürsten-Abo?
Ökonomen nennen diese Abo-Flut übrigens ...
Hast du schon mal Proxmox auf einem Hetzner-Root-Server installiert?
Nee.
Aber ich stell mir das nicht so unterschiedlich vor zu anderen Systemen.
Was ist da alles im Warenkorb?
Das ist eine sehr berechtigte Frage, ich weiß es auch nicht mehr.
Äh, Interdentalbürsten?
Pferdesalbe, USB-Sticks, Mount für mein Fahrrad-Stelzkram ...
Äh ...
Ja.
SAP-Software zu administrieren, pain as fuck, das denke ich mir.
Ja, Rasierklingen-Abo und sowas.
Das Blöde ist, dass Amazon oftmals, wenn du Produkte neu bestellst, diesen Abo-Ding als Default-Kaufoption auswählt.
Da musst du wirklich genau gucken und sagen, nein, nein, einmal Kauf.
Nee, hab ich nicht.
Was hast du denn für ein Problem mit deinem Hetzner-Server?
Das ist Subscription Economy.
Und die wird sich sehr wahrscheinlich noch viel stärker ausbreiten.
Schaut mal.
Diese Kurve zeigt, wie sich die Umsätze der größten US-amerikanischen Unternehmen in den letzten zehn Jahren entwickelt haben.
Toilettenpapier im Abo gibt es garantiert.
Und diese Kurve hier zeigt, wie sich die Einnahmen ...
Warum Unraid offen ist?
Weil Unraid jetzt auch Subscription macht, obwohl sie offiziell nicht sagen, dass sie Subscription machen.
... Unternehmen entwickelt haben, die auf Abo-Modelle setzen.
Die sind einfach viermal so stark gestiegen.
In den USA hat die Abo-Flut also ziemlich krasse Ausmaße angenommen.
Laut einer Studie zahlt der durchschnittliche Amerikaner fast 220 Dollar für Abonnements.
Für Deutschland gibt es dazu leider noch keine Zahl.
Das krieg ich aber auch hin.
Besonders interessant ist dabei aber eine andere Zahl.
Denn die Studie hat auch herausgefunden, dass 84 Prozent der Amerikaner ihre Abo-Ausgaben unterschätzen.
Und genau das ist auch die Gefahr, die unser Experte Noah Leidinger in der Abo-Flut sieht.
Ich glaube schon, dass viele Leute sehr viel für Subscriptions ausgeben.
Da musst du jetzt so wirklich kein Experte für sein, um zu erkennen, dass du da schnell den Überblick verlierst, oder?
Eben, das oft auch gar nicht mehr so im Blick haben, weil halt die einzelnen Kosten relativ klein sind.
Und da kommen dann schnell mal Kosten von 50 Dollar im Monat zusammen, obwohl man immer nur so kleine Verträge abschließt.
Teilweise nimmt das ziemlich absurde Ausmaße an.
BMW zum Beispiel hat 2022 ...
Wenn dein Hootserver bei Hexer nicht mal startet, musst du in diese komische ...
Wie heißt das bei Hexer? Recovery-Konsole oder so?
Kann man bei Hootserver mit Hexer nicht die Grafikausgabe redirecten, dass du selbst gucken kannst, wo er hängt?
Das weiß ich nicht, was man da am besten macht.
... ein Sitzheizungs-Abo eingeführt. Kein Scheiß.
Ja, ich sag doch BMW. Wir hatten es doch am Anfang des Streams vorhin.
Da habe ich doch noch gesagt, ich glaube, bei BMW kostet das doch schon was, Sitzheizung zu benutzen, ja?
Dann hab ich das schwarz auf weiß eingeführt. Kein Scheiß.
Also, wer einen warmen Hintern haben wollte, musste einfach 17 Euro im Monat latzen, um die Sitzheizung freizuschalten.
Das gab einen ziemlichen Aufschrei und an alle empörten BMW-Kunden mit Sitzheizungs-Abo
hat die Renault-Tochter Dacia daraufhin gratis Wärmflaschen verteilt. Einfach nur, um ein bisschen zu stacheln.
Die ganze Nummer ist BMW dann doch zu heiß geworden und man hat sich in München wieder von der Idee verabschiedet.
Aber auch wenn BMW in Sachen Abo nicht ...
Aber das ist normal. Die loten jetzt einfach aus.
Man weiß nicht, wie weit man das ganze treiben kann zum aktuellen Zeitpunkt.
Und das muss man auch alle paar Jahre neu machen, weil irgendwann akzeptieren es die Leute vielleicht.
... durchgezogen hat. Die Idee hat unsere Art zu konsumieren für immer verändert.
Prio Nummer 1 ist deshalb, Überblick behalten in dem ganzen Abo-Wahnsinn.
Dafür gibt es zum Beispiel ziemlich praktische Apps im Abo, selbstverständlich.
Man kann auch einfach eine TXT-Datei machen und reinschreiben, was man alles abonniert.
Brauche keine extra App für.
Adobe hat mit seinem Abo-Modell alles auf eine Karte gesetzt und gewonnen.
Mittlerweile zählt der Photoshop-Konzern einfach zu den wertvollsten Unternehmen der Welt.
Gleichzeitig sollte das Beispiel Adobe aber auch eine Warnung sein.
Denn mittlerweile besitzt Adobe mit seinem Programm, zumindest in einigen Bereichen, so was wie ein Monopol.
Und das ist für uns Kunden erstmal nicht so gut.
Erst recht nicht, wenn man beruflich auch noch auf diese Software angewiesen ist.
Was die Abo-Flut im Allgemeinen angeht, bin ich so ein bisschen zwiegespalten.
Auf der einen Seite sind die super bequem und man ist immer auf dem neuesten Stand.
Auf der anderen Seite möchte ich aber nicht, dass mir gefühlt jeder Scheiß im Abo vertickt wird, den es vorher auch normal zu haben gab.
Der Erfolg dieses Geschäftsmodells, vor allem in den USA, zeigt aber, dass wir da gerade erst am Anfang stehen.
So, das war unsere Analyse zur Abo-Flut. Ich hoffe, es hat euch gefallen.
Hier findet ihr noch ein Video aus dem Funk-Kosmos.
Es gibt genug, die das probiert haben und es nicht funktioniert.
Es gibt ja zu Photoshop durchaus, je nach Einsatzzweck, Alternativen.
Ich benutze ja auch Affinity Designer zum Beispiel für Thumbnails und nicht Photoshop.
Aber insgesamt ist das schon sehr etabliert.
Und im Videoschnittbereich benutzt ja auch keiner wirklich Premiere im professionellen Umfeld.
Wenig Premiere.
Das ist eher was für YouTube-Creator und irgendwelche Marketing-Agenturen und sowas.
Aber Filme werden so gut wie nie in Premiere zum Beispiel geschnitten.
Aber trotzdem, dieser ganze Kosmos aus Adobe-Produkten hat schon eine ziemlich große Stellung.
Was empfiehlt uns YouTube denn noch?
Ohne Kleber fürs Klima, das neue hin und her...
Oh ne, please, da habe ich jetzt echt keinen Nerv drauf.
Warum will YouTube unbedingt, dass ich mir das hier angucke?
Mit was werden dann Filme geschnitten?
Also, Blackmagic ist in diesem Bereich echt ziemlich nice dabei.
Dann gibt es, wie heißt dieses Apple-Ding?
Final Cut oder so machen auch einige.
Und ansonsten, wie die ganzen Filmstudios, was die benutzen, keine Ahnung.
Auf jeden Fall nicht Premiere.
Sehr selten Premiere.
Avid, ja sowas, genau, genau, das ist auch sehr beliebt da.
Also, was haben wir denn sonst noch?
Elon's Brain Chips actually work on humans.
Ah, Fireship-Video, Fireship ist immer nice.
Nochmal Fireship.
How I deploy serverless containers for free.
Leute, ich wette mit euch, das ist mit Adobe, äh, nicht Adobe, jetzt fängt es schon wieder an.
Mit Oracle Cloud Free Tier.
Könnte ich wetten.
Wobei, ich habe das auch schon mal versucht.
Ich wollte mal das Oracle Free Tier ausprobieren.
Aber da wollten die, dass ich mich mit Kreditkarte und allem registriere und da hatte ich keinen Bock drauf.
Oh, Weep-Musik, Leute.
Nee, nee, nee, jetzt nicht.
Ich will euch nicht zu sehr quälen.
Gucken wir uns mal das an.
Fireship macht immer nice Videos.
Ernsthaft?
Habe ich gar nicht mitgekriegt.
Ich frage mich, wer das freiwillig macht.
Na gut, wobei, doch, frage ich mich eigentlich nicht.
Gibt es genug Freiwillige?
Es gibt ja auch genug Freiwillige, die sich auf den Mars schicken lassen wollten und sowas.
We heard nothing but crickets.
Based on the prior testing results with monkeys,
doctors, scientists and Elon-Haters all over the world feared the worst.
They assumed the Encephalon likely exploded and patient zero did not survive.
Finally, yesterday we learned the truth.
The Neuralink install was a success and the results are absolutely mind-blowing.
First ever user of the Neuralink device.
And I think you're my only telekinetic friend that I have.
Yeah, I hope so.
It is March 21st, 2024 and you're watching The Code Report.
This is Nolan Arbaugh.
He's a 29 year old who was paralyzed from the shoulder down in a diving accident.
That's not the best card to be dealt in life.
But over the last few weeks, he's gained telekinetic-like abilities.
Ich habe jetzt mal eine Frage.
Wie schafft man das?
Also, wie wird man querschnittsgelähmt vom Tauchen?
Was muss da passieren?
Also, bei Stürzen und so kann ich mir das vorstellen.
Aber beim Tauchen, was muss da passieren?
Wir sehen ja, dass es funktioniert, aber...
Sauerstoffmangel?
Okay, Sauerstoffmangel, Gehirnschäden und dann...
Ja, gut, vielleicht, ja.
Verkehrsunfall mit U-Boot.
Ja, sicherlich das wahrscheinlichste Szenario.
...possible at first glance.
Like here he's controlling a mouse cursor to play games like Chess and Civ 6 using nothing but his thoughts.
There's no eye tracking or sensors
other than the chip in his brain.
In today's video, we'll find out exactly how this crazy technology works
and make some predictions about where things are going in the future.
But first, I think humanity owes this guy a huge amount of respect and appreciation.
The average person thinks they're brave for being an early adopter of the Cybertruck,
but it takes real balls of stainless steel to order the Foundation Series Neuralink.
What's crazy is that the chip itself is not installed by a human surgeon,
but rather a surgical robot.
After drilling a hole into your cranium,
it implants a bunch of tiny threads that are finer than a human hair.
It uses a tiny needle like a sewing machine to weave these threads into your brain.
Each thread contains high-density electrodes,
which are capable of detecting electrical activity, also known as brainwaves.
Wann lässt du dich chippen?
War das nicht so, dass uns Bill Gates mit der Corona-Impfung schon alle heimlich gechippt hat?
It has 1024 electrodes distributed across 64 threads,
which means you have 16 electrodes per...
Moment, jetzt hab ich jetzt nicht aufgepasst.
...detecting electrical activity, also known as brainwaves.
The N1 chip has 1024 electrodes distributed across 64 threads,
which means you have 16 electrodes per thread.
To put that in perspective, a typical electroencephalogram will have around 20 sensors,
and they typically max out around 256 electrodes.
In addition, they're on the outside of your skull,
which means you're more likely to get interference before that signal reaches the electrode.
The only real advantage is that you don't have to drill a hole into your skull.
The N1 transmits data wirelessly and is powered by a small lithium-ion battery,
and that battery is charged wirelessly from the outside via...
Geil! Musst du dir dein Ladegerät an den Kopf halten!
...an inductive charger.
But the big question here is, how is this guy actually moving a mouse with his thoughts?
Well, in order to understand that, we need to learn a little bit about brainwaves.
When you're asleep, your brain emits low-frequency delta waves around 2 Hertz.
When you wake up and become a little more alert,
they increase their frequency to alpha waves at around 10 Hertz.
And then finally, when you become highly focused,
like when solving a coding problem or playing chess,
they become gamma waves at around 35 Hertz.
And that's what we're most interested in measuring,
because we can recognize certain wave patterns, just like a sound wave,
which can identify a distinct thought in your brain.
They didn't provide a ton of detail in the Neuralink video,
but he might have a thought, like move my right arm,
that creates a specific type of electrical signal in his brain.
The chip itself can then pick up on that,
which triggers an action to move the mouse to the right.
But that doesn't happen magically right after the surgery.
There's a brain computer interface
where the end user needs to practice a bunch of movements
because everybody's brainwaves are different
and it needs to learn which thoughts correspond to which movements.
Now, if you have working arms and legs, you might not be all that excited.
But for many, this technology could be life changing,
especially when integrated with futuristic technologies.
Like today we have wheelchairs, but in the not so distant future,
they could be replaced by mech suits that are entirely controlled by the person's brain.
I know that sounds crazy,
but the field of robotics is also popping off right now.
Figure One has incredible human like dexterity
and NVIDIA just announced their own humanoid robots.
And it's only a matter of time before there's an Apple Robot Pro.
When brain chips and robotics converge in the near future,
human disabilities may be far less restricted.
And that's a big win for humanity.
Now, brain chips do have their skeptics for obvious reasons.
But luckily, the data only flows one way.
You don't have to worry about getting KFC advertisements injected into your dreams
and they won't be able to turn off important bodily functions
if you don't pay your monthly subscription.
Also, they can't really identify highly
complex thoughts, which means there's no need to worry about being thrown in jail
for wrong think while the NSA monitors your thoughts.
And most importantly, there won't be an API for JavaScript developers to build out.
Noch nicht, noch nicht.
Aber wir dürfen nicht vergessen,
SpaceX fliegt auch mit JavaScript und Elektronen in Weltall.
Now finally, the good news is that you can be an early adopter as well.
Clinical trials are open for the Neuralink Prime study,
where you can get your Founders Edition brain chip.
To sign up with the link on screen.
Full disclosure, this video is not sponsored
and I don't get paid if you don't survive the trial.
So come with me if you want to not die.
This has been The Code Report.
Thanks for watching and I will see you in the next one.
Abgedrehtes Zeug, man.
Würde sich das irgendjemand machen lassen von euch?
Findet das jemand von euch so aufregend,
das Thema, dass er sagen würde, ich lass mir das machen?
Gibt ja genug, wie gesagt, es gibt auch Leute, die werden freiwillig auf den Mars geflogen.
Ja, vielleicht, wenn man querschnittsgelähmt ist oder gelähmt
ist, dann hat man da wohl, denke ich, auch deutlich mehr zu gewinnen draus.
Ja, wenn man so lernen könnte wie in Matrix.
Ja, das wäre natürlich nice.
Ich kann, ich kann jetzt Kung Fu.
Ob man da den Ping im Gehirn messen kann?
Ja, das ist eine gute Frage.
Dann bekommt das Wort Brain Lack ganz neue Dimensionen.
Ja, wenn man so instant Fremdsprachen upgraden könnte und so, wäre schon nice.
Wobei dann halt die Frage ist,
wenn das alle hätten, gäbe es dann überhaupt noch so viele unterschiedliche Sprachen?
Würde man sich da nicht trotzdem auf irgendeine
Gemeinsame, die alle easy dadurch lernen können, beschränken?
Zumindest wenn das irgendwann mal
Mainstream ist, in langer, langer, weiterer Zukunft
gibt es bestimmt dort auch Microtransactions und Ingame Shops und sowas.
Und das Ganze läuft auf JavaScript Basis.
Vielleicht, vielleicht aber auch auf Rust Basis blazingly fast.
Dann musst du regelmäßige Firmware Updates für dein Gehirn machen.
Was haben wir sonst noch?
Wir wollen.
Das interessiert mich nicht.
Aber das haben wir doch schon geguckt, dass.
Das KI Zeug habe jetzt so arbeitet eine Partner Vermittlung.
Da habe ich ja first first hand Erfahrung, was Partner
Vermittlungsunternehmen angeht.
Da first second hand.
Microsofts Größe.
Was ist aus Battle Bit geworden?
Gute Frage.
Wann haben wir das nicht schon geguckt?
Sehe ich da PHP?
Ist das PHP?
Das sieht so hässlich und wie aus mit den Dollars.
Das ist doch das ist PHP, oder?
Leiser.
Was ist dein Favorites?
Ich habe es nicht in einem Bad gemacht.
Ich habe es mit.
Drop Drop gemacht.
Mit drauf drauf tröpfeln.
Was ist dein Favorites Proxy?
Das ist eine sehr gute, eine nahezu exzellente Frage.
In welchem Kontext?
Ich kann dir das beantworten.
Mein Allround Lieblings Reverse Proxy ist Nginx.
Für einfache Sachen ist es Kaddi und im Kubernetes Umfeld ist
es auch Nginx.
Für Customizable Sachen, wo man spezielle
Health Checks und sowas braucht, HA Proxy.
Was ich nicht mag, ist Traffic.
Und Apache.
Oder Internet Information Service Server.
Wie heißt das überhaupt?
Wobei kann man damit überhaupt gescheit reverse?
Ja, wahrscheinlich.
Benutzt doch irgendjemand IIS.
Also Traffic mag ich nicht.
Kaddi mag ich auch.
Ähm, Apache mag ich auch nicht.
Und habe ich noch was vergessen?
Ich meine, im Kubernetes Umfeld gibt es enorm viel anderes Zeug noch dafür.
Aber.
Also auch mit Load Balancing Funktionen und allem.
Aber ich glaube, dass das war so im Großen und Ganzen, was da verbreitet ist.
Gibt Kunden, die unbedingt IIS nutzen wollen.
Ja, man versteht manchmal die Leute auch nicht.
Nginx Proxy Manager hat jetzt aber
nur sekundär was mit Reverse Proxy zu tun.
Das ist ein Web Interface, um Nginx als Reverse Proxy zu konfigurieren.
Inklusive Let's Encrypt Zertifikats Handling.
Istio ist ein bisschen was anderes. Istio ist ein Service Mesh.
Da kannst du beispielsweise
gucken, wie der Traffic von Container zu Container fließt und so Zeug.
Das ist Istio ist ein Service.
Sowas wie LinkAD zum Beispiel.
Ist auch ein Service Mesh.
Da kannst du auch relativ easy MTLS machen,
also sprich verschlüsselte Kommunikation zwischen zwischen Containern,
weil die Container dann quasi nicht mehr so direkt miteinander reden, sondern
automatisch connected werden über das Service Mesh und so miteinander.
Ja, da hast du dann quasi so ein Sidecar
Container, was Verschlüsselung macht, dann ist dann die
In-Cluster Kommunikation verschlüsselt mit MTLS.
Sowas kannst du damit machen.
Istio ist jetzt kein, würde ich sagen, so Nginx Reverse Proxy Ersatz.
Der Standard, der Standard Kubernetes
ist ja auch auf Nginx Basis.
Und wohlgemerkt Nginx Ingress ist was anderes wie Ingress Nginx,
weil die Benahmung mal wieder kacke ist.
Was hat NPM mit Docker Networks zu tun?
Diese drei Sachen ergeben ergeben für mich jetzt absolut keinen Sinn zusammen.
Für euch Chatge.
NPM ist der Package Manager von NodeJS.
Docker Network ist das eine.
Okay, Unraid. Aber was hat Imich damit jetzt zu tun?
Das ist ein Service, den du in Docker laufen lassen würdest.
Vielleicht.
Das verstehe ich nicht, was du willst.
Ach, Nginx Proxy Manager.
Ach so.
Ja, das auch.
Ja gut, das ist eine Android Konfigurationssache.
Ja, gar nicht, oder?
Brauchst du nicht.
Du brauchst das Ding braucht mehrere Netzwerk Interfaces.
Der bräuchte der Container, bräuchte mehrere, mehrere Netzwerkkarten.
Den unterschiedlichen Netzen hängen dann wahrscheinlich.
Habe ich mir noch keine Gedanken drüber gemacht.
Ich
hatte gestern seit Ewigkeiten mal wieder einen Stromausfall.
Und ich habe das dadurch gemerkt,
dass meine ganzen Steckdosen, meine ganzen smarten Steckdosen geplinkt haben,
weil die nicht mehr zu ihrem MQTT Video zu ihrem MQTT Server gekommen sind.
Muss aber nur ganz kurzer Stromausfall
gewesen sein, weil manche Sachen sind eindeutig weitergelaufen.
Aber die Raspberry Pi sind beispielsweise auch abgekackt.
Und übrigens diese Steckdosen Leisten, die
ich hier ein paar Mal geflasht habe im Stream.
Ich habe nicht die von Hammer, aber das ist die.
Die gibt es von Hammer.
Ja, die gibt es.
Das ist China Chinesen Steckdosen Leiste.
Die gibt es von 50 verschiedenen Herstellern.
Und die hatte lange Zeit einen ESP 2866 drin, dass er die Custom Firmware flashen kann.
Davon sind mir jetzt innerhalb von einer Woche drei Stück kaputt gegangen.
Eine im Keller gestern beim Stromausfall.
Eine hier, wo mein Rechner dran hängt.
Und die, die ich hier neben mir liegen habe mit Ladegeräten dran, wo mein
Ring Light ist, wenn ich mal was streamen muss mit Bastel Kram.
In einer Woche drei Stück.
Die sind dann auch ungefähr alle gleich alt.
Ich bin, ich bin mir halt jetzt unschlüssig.
Ist es ein Fehler von den Steckdosen Leisten?
Also ja, ist es auf jeden Fall.
Oder ist irgendwas mit meinem Stromnetz daheim im Arsch, dass die Dinger das
einfach nur, weil die fragil sind, das als erstes merken?
Drei Stück innerhalb von einer Woche oder
eineinhalb Wochen sind wir da jetzt verreckt.
Wobei ich glaube, die Steckdosenleiste ist einfach im Arsch.
Es ist wie kaputt.
Wenn du sie in Strom steckst.
Nee, aufgeschraubt habe ich die nicht.
Ja, ich könnte mal reingucken tatsächlich, ob da irgendwas verkohlt ist oder so.
Also wenn du sie in Strom steckst.
Ja, die sind über ein Jahr alt.
Meine.
Die sind, meine sind schon drei Jahre oder so alt.
Wie die jetzt kaputt gegangen sind.
Also mal gespannt.
Wie lange, wie lange deine noch halten.
Also wenn was mit der Steckdosenleiste jetzt passiert ist, wenn du sie jetzt in
Strom steckst, dann gehen die Lichter nicht mehr an die LEDs, was so viel heißt
wie der Microcontroller da drin wird auch nicht mehr mit Strom versorgt.
Und dementsprechend schalten da auch keine Relays und nichts mehr.
Und die Steckdosenleiste geht halt einfach nicht mehr.
Eventuell haben die Überspannung Schutz, den du resetten musst.
Haben die nicht, oder so was haben die nicht.
Die sind nicht so.
Sind nicht so advanced.
Kein Überspannung Schutz, den man hier resetten kann.
Den ESP könnte man wechseln.
Ich glaube nicht, dass es am ESP selber liegt.
Ich glaube, dass da drinne irgendwas kaputt gegangen ist und dadurch der ESP zerstört wurde.
Also sprich, selbst wenn man da jetzt den neuen ESP reinmacht und noch mal das Motor
drauf flasht, dann wird er wahrscheinlich auch wieder instant kaputt gehen.
Also.
Setke.
Kaputt.
Ich steck die jetzt noch mal rein und dann gucken wir mal, was passiert.
Aber wahrscheinlich nix.
Ne, nix.
Dead.
Komplett dead.
Das Ding.
Detke.
Macht einfach gar nix mehr.
Detke. Setke.
Ne, kann ich wieder rausziehen.
Ich glaube, das war's mit China-Chinesen Steckdosenleisten.
Ich werde mir irgendwie noch eine normale wieder hinstellen.
Aber es ist schon verdächtig, dass drei
Stück innerhalb von eineinhalb Wochen verreckt sind, oder?
An das Trinken erinnern.
Nein, heute keine Nudeln mit Lachs.
Heute Spaghetti, Tomatensohsargfleisch.
Telefonieren die nach draußen?
Ja, wenn du die mit Standard China-Firmware betreibst, eventuell.
Aber ich betreibe die ja nicht mit Standard China-Firmware.
Ich habe die ja geflasht mit Tasmota und das telefoniert garantiert nicht nach draußen.
Zumal ich die auch noch zusätzlich in meinem IoT
und WLAN hängen habe, was nur Zugriff, also was kein Internetzugriff hat,
was nur Zugriff auf meinen MQTT-Server hat und sonst nix.
Und auf NTP für Zeit, Uhrzeit.
Tasmota hängt übrigens, wenn es keinen Zugriff auf NTP hat.
Ist auch Ding, was ich lernen musste, was nirgendwo steht.
Wird Tasmota eigentlich noch weiterentwickelt?
Hat schon lange, lange nix mehr mitgemacht.
Ja.
1.4, weißt du.
Chat, was machen wir denn jetzt noch?
Aber irgendwas Gutes, was wir noch gucken können?
Ich krieg übelst Hunger gerade schon.
Aber ich bin ja auch erst so spät angekommen.
Wollen wir noch ein FireShip-Video gucken?
Mach das mal.
Hast du übrigens mitbekommen bei den Fritz-Boxen, mit denen...
Ja, habe ich mitbekommen.
Ja, ja, das kenne ich.
Ja, ja.
Ja.
Ja, das kenne ich.
Das war...
Ist so eine, so eine NFT-Handelseite
oder sowas, wo man bei fritz.box rausgekommen ist.
Wobei die, glaube ich, mittlerweile abgeschaltet wurde.
Moment, drei bis vier Gigabyte Traffic am Tag.
Was macht die Waschmaschine denn da?
Das ist ja schon enorm.
Ich meine, nicht Internet-Traffic, einfach wie...
Wobei, ja, wohin soll es denn sonst was schicken?
Drei bis vier Gigabyte am Tag.
Das ist enorm viel, Mann.
Hast du mal irgendwie mitgeschnitten, was die macht?
War schon wahrscheinlich verschlüsselt, oder?
Kannst wahrscheinlich nichts sehen.
Aber du müsstest zumindest sehen, wohin die connected.
Downloaded Wasser.
Ist ja ganz weird.
Ich glaube, das liegt auch daran.
Ich, ich würde, ich würde den Herstellern nicht mal böse Absichten unbedingt unterstellen.
Ich glaube, gerade von diesen Dingern ist auch sehr viel unfähig programmiert.
Vielleicht meint die ja Kryptogramm.
Leute, wisst ihr was?
Ich gehe jetzt was fressen.
Ich habe Hunger.
Heute kein Lachs mit Nudel.
User of LG Washing Machine spotted
der Lizenz 11 Gigabit of Traffic.
What the fuck?
Was macht das Ding da, Alter?
Kam da irgendwas raus bei dem Thread?
Was machen die da?
Man hat keinerlei Zugriff auf das Gerät.
Deswegen wird das auch
schwierig zu man in the middlen.
Simple Explanation Internet of Shits.
Das ist auch ein nicer Account, den den lese ich auch öfter.
Ja, so wirklich, so wirklich was rausbekommen hat man da jetzt aber auch nicht.
Oder ist das ist schon ein ziemlicher Fail.
Ich glaube, so Sachen sind auch oftmals sehr.
Ja,
flüchtig und mies programmiert.
Also ich hab Punkt Zip komplett exkludiert in meinem Router als Domains Punkt Zip wird bei mir
einfach default nicht aufgelöst.
Hab ich gemacht an dem Tag, als die Zip Domains live ging.
Es finde ich eines der unnötigsten Moves gewesen überhaupt.
Punkt Zip als Domain.
Okay, alles klar.
Ich geh jetzt was fressen.
Bis später. Macht's gut.
See you.